[Applaus]
und stellvertretend für alle
steilsteilstreitkräfte und Truppen des
österreichischen Bundesheers darf ich
begrüßen den Kommandanten der dritten
Jäger Brigade Brigitte Christian
Habersatter den Kommandanten der vierten
Jäger Brigade reagiert
Horst Hofer den Kommandanten des ja
Kommandos reagiert Philipp segür kavanak
den stellvertreten Militärkommandanten
von Wien dann oberste Leopold Schieder
sowie den Miliz Beauftragten des
österreichischen Bundesheers ein
generalmaier Erwin ameseder herzlich
willkommen liebe Kamera
[Applaus]
und last but not least darf ich mich
bedanken für das Kommen und freue mich
sehr dass hochrangige Persönlichkeiten
die in der Vergangenheit das
österreichische Bundesheer sehr sehr
stark geprägt haben auch heute wieder
den Weg zu uns gefunden haben sie sind
häufig Gäste bei unseren Veranstaltungen
bitte begrüßen Sie mit mir
stellvertretend für alle Soldaten des
ruhe- und reservestandes die Generäle
Karl Metzen Günter Greindl jan ist König
und den kanalleitern
herzlich willkommen meine Herren
[Applaus]
und nunmehr darf ich dir liebe Frau
Bundesminister das Wort übergeben um zum
vierten Mal
Grußworte an die Versammlung zu richten
sehr geehrter Herr
Präsident Vorsitzender Brigitte Erich
sehr geehrter Herr generalstabchef Herr
korkumandant Freunde Gäste aus der
Schweiz unter aus Deutschland sehr
geehrte Herrn wersprecher Ehrengäste
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren hier im
Saal und alle die uns zuhören
Soldatinnen Soldaten des Präsenz des
Mittelstandes in der Regel in Ruhe sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
ein besonderer Tag heute mit und das ist
angeklungen in den Eröffnungsworten mit
sehr vielen premieren
das ist auch kein Wunder weil es ein
historischer Tag ist heute
der Tag wo wir zurückdenken zehn Jahre
zurückdenken wo es um nicht mehr und
nicht weniger gegangen ist als die um
die Zukunft des österreichischen
Bundesheeres als heute genau vor zehn
Jahren sich 59,7 Prozent der
Österreicherinnen und Österreicher für
die Wehrpflicht entschieden haben ich
war damals nicht in der Funktion aber
das was ich schon gemacht habe gibt es
einige in diesen reinen
kann ich habe dafür gekämpft du hast
auch am vorderster Front in einem
Bundesland
ja und vor genau drei Jahren
wenige Tage nach meinem Amtsantritt bin
ich eben hier gestanden als erste
Verteidigungsministerin der Republik
Österreich in diesen wunderschönen
hallenort dieser Stelle ein ganz großes
Dankeschön noch für den Reisekette
Generalsekretär so schön wieder hier zu
sein und ich habe wörtlich damals
folgendes gesagt
ein schwieriger ein steiler Weg liegt
vor uns aber wir wollen das notwendige
möglich machen das österreichische
Bundesheer braucht zukunftsfähige
Ressourcen und Strukturen dazu moderne
Ausrüstung und neues Gerät es stehen
gewaltige Entscheidungen bei
beschaffungsvorgängen an mich selbst
fordern Herausforderungen und ich bin
felsenfest überzeugt wir werden das für
die Landesverteidigung gemeinsam
meistern
und wenn hier neben mir beim Vorgänger
generalmaier Stallinger sitzt dann
kommen in diese Worte nicht mehr von
dieser Veranstaltung bekannt vor sondern
auch von der Amtsübergabe im Hof der
Rossauer Kaserne
und wenn ich diese Worte oder wenn Sie
bitte mit mir diese Worte so ein
bisschen überdenken
dann glaube ich sind wir mitten drinnen
dann sind wir mitten drinnen da bin ich
wieder beim Wort gemeinsam schön dass
alle wer Sprecher aller Parteien heute
da sind dann sind wir dabei gemeinsam
aus unserem österreichischen Bundesheer
ein modernes her zu gestalten dass auch
tatsächlich seinen
verfassungsrechtlichen Aufgaben
nachkommen kann und diese erfüllen kann
wir tun dies unter dem Motto Mission
vorwärts mit der Beschaffung von
Ausrüstung Waffen und Gerät genauso wie
attraktiven Maßnahmen auch für unser
wohl wichtigstes Kapital nämlich unser
Personal
daher auch schön dass der Vertreter der
Personalvertretung lieber Walter heute
auch hier ist für unsere Soldatinnen
Soldaten für die Zivilbediensteten die
tagtäglich den Schutz und Sicherheit
unseres Landes herstellen und die dienen
und ich kann sagen ein bisschen Bilanz
können wir schon gemeinsam ziehen es ist
uns durchaus einiges gelungen es ist uns
einiges gelungen in diesen letzten zehn
Jahren insbesondere Ihnen den Vertretern
der mittlerweile 19 Organisationen die
sich eingesetzt haben und wie es du es
richtig angesprochen hast das wird auch
hinkünftig weiter notwendig sein das zu
tun
ich kann erst drei Jahre
zurückblicken in dieser Funktion und
wenn auch heute ein Tag der Freude auf
der einen Seite ist dann ist es auch
schon richtig angesprochen worden
insbesondere die letzten drei Jahre
waren Jahre in denen unglaublich vieles
passiert ist die Pandemie hat auch dazu
geführt dass dieser Tag nicht
stattfinden konnte ja virtuell
stattfinden konnte und so schöner dass
das halt doppelt nämlich auch Hybrid
passiert ja und dann der Angriff
Russland auf die Ukraine der wohl alles
verändert hat nicht nur in Österreich
alles verändert hat
wenn wir daran denken sehr geehrte Damen
und Herren was uns gemeinsam gelungen
ist wenn wir an diese zahlreichen
Einsätze zum einen Denken im Inland und
im Ausland wenn wir daran denken was
unsere Soldatinnen und Soldaten
geleistet haben im Inland und im Ausland
und was uns gemeinsam gelungen ist weil
man Sicherheit
nicht aus der parteipolitischen Brille
betrachtet hat schon gar nicht die
militärische Sicherheit sondern diese
werden ab davon gesehen hat wir haben es
geschafft das höchste heeresbudget in
der Geschichte des Bundesheeres zu
erreichen 16 Milliarden die nächsten
vier Jahre ein
landesverteidigungsfinanzierungsgesetz
dass es so noch nie gegeben hat dass uns
eben den Aufbauplan über den heute
Generalstabschef stridinger noch viele
sehr zählen wird und ich bin überzeugt
davon auch noch sehr viel diskutiert
werden wird das haben wir beschlossen
also schon denke ich Meilensteine die
gelungen sind und wenn ich von den
großen Beschaffungsprozessen spreche
dann gerade vor Weihnachten konnten wir
gemeinsam es waren ja auch die
wehrsprecher damit dabei den ersten
unserer insgesamt 36 neuen Hubschrauber
ja wir haben die Flotte verdoppelt das
ist damit nach den SAP 105 die
zweitgrößte Flotte die das
österreichische Bundesheer jemals hatte
dann ist du schon sehr vieles gelungen
und wenn man sich so das eine oder
andere Zitat so wie du das jetzt
vorgelesen hast
anschaut dann stimmt es einen schon
nachdenklich was den wer Willen
anbelangt dann sieht man das gerade
dieser Dachverband wie alle gemeinsam
noch sehr viel an Arbeit vor uns haben
wenn man auf der anderen Seite sich aber
dann die Meinungsumfragen anschaut die
Abfragen wie die österreichische
Bevölkerung das Bundesheer sieht und
dort erkennt wie das Vertrauen gestiegen
ist gerade in den letzten Jahren dann
glaube ich können wir mit frischem in
das neue Jahr und in diese durchaus
herausfordernden Zeiten hineingehen wir
haben vieles vor Sie werden davon noch
einiges hören ohne Zweifel viele
Versäumnisse die in der Vergangenheit
erfolgt sind weil man ohne einer
Bewertung eben vielleicht die soziale
Sicherheit über die militärische
Sicherheit gestellt hat wenn man sich
auf einer Insel oder seligen gefühlt hat
da gibt es viele
Überlegungen die man rückblickend
würde aber wir haben vorbereitet zu sein
nicht nur auf regionale Konflikte auf
den Ukraine kriegt auf
Bedrohungsszenarien wie
terrorismus-pandemien auf all das was
passiert ist oder was als wahrscheinlich
geht nach dem Experten meines Hauses wir
haben vorbereitet zu sein weil wir
wissen dass wir zur Bewältigung von
jeweiligen Krisen immer herangezogen
werden und auch da kann diskutiert
werden was ist die Grundaufgabe die
Grundaufgabe
besteht ja außer Frage ist
verfassungsrechtlich auch
determiniert aber der Grundauftrag des
Bundesheeres ist auch darauf
ausgerichtet zu funktionieren wenn sonst
nichts mehr geht
und was nicht funktionieren würde das
wäre wohl das österreichische Bundesheer
ohne der Wehrpflicht davon bin ich
zutiefst überzeugt
es wurden heute schon die Zeitungen des
heutigen Tages auch zitiert mir hat ich
habe ihn jetzt in den Reihen nicht
gesehen die Aussage von General
enttacher die habe ich als sehr treffend
gefunden der da sagte die Wehrpflicht
bringt zum einen die notwendige
Mannstärke sie sorgt aber auch für die
demokratische Durchflutung der
Streitkräfte und diese Mischung ist es
die ideal ist daher die Basis in
Wahrheit für alles
ohne Wehrpflicht gibt es keine
Grundwehrdiener ohne Grundwehrdiener
keine Kadersoldaten und auch keine Miliz
und ich stehe daher hier und sagt danke
danke dir Herr Vorsitzender danke allen
Vereinen danke der Plattform wehrhaftes
österreich-stellvertretend natürlich dir
Herr präsidiert für das unglaublich
große Engagement für die Sicherheit und
zum Schutz der Republik Österreich
vielen Dank
das ist der Moment wo geklatscht werden
können
und in Wahrheit haben sie ja nicht nur
ihren Vorsitzenden
geklatscht sondern sie haben ja auch
sich selber Beifall gespendet das eine
ist der Aufbauplan über den heute viel
gesprochen werden wird der eine
Grundlage hat ja man kann nicht durchaus
Stallinger Bericht nennen wir mussten
natürlich dann das eine oder andere noch
adaptieren bei uns im Haus erleben Dinge
passiert sind die so nicht vorhersehbar
waren aber das das die Grundlage dieses
aufbauplanes war da steht auch außer
Frage und daher dir an dieser Stelle
lieber Herr Generalmajor ein ganz großes
Dankeschön für den Weitblick den du im
Jahr 2019 in der Funktion als
Verteidigungsminister gezeigt hast danke
dir
[Applaus]
materialbeschaffungen das wichtigste
aber immer das Personal ich denke auch
da ist uns ich schaue jetzt die
wehrsprecher an etwas gelungen das ist
ja beinahe zehn Jahren nicht gegeben hat
denn seit heuer mit Beginn des Monats
jänner gibt es mehr Geld für die
Grundwehrdiener bei einer 10 Jahre hat
sich hier nichts getan und jetzt sind es
seit Jahresbeginn 536 Euro wir haben
einen leadsbonus geschaffen noch mal 400
Euro monatlich wenn sich jemand zur
Miliz meldet dann weitere 200 Euro für
jene die dekadeausbildung absolvieren
und die zusätzlichen Leistungen quasi
das Rundum-Paket wie auch Unkosten
Beihilfe da steht auch außer Frage ich
bin überzeugt davon dass heute viel
diskutiert werden wird über die
Personalfrage die nicht nur uns als
verteidigungsressor bewegt den
öffentlichen Dienst bewegt in Wahrheit
mittlerweile alle Branchen bewegt und es
steht außer Frage dass mehr
geübt werden muss die vergangenen Jahre
waren
Belastungen durch
Unterstützungsleistungen Assistenz
Aufgaben Anforderungen in den
verschiedensten Bereichen die zum einen
dazu geführt haben dass die Ausbildung
auf der einen oder anderen Seite
gelitten hat ja auch dazu geführt hat
dass man das warum man Soldat Soldatin
wird nicht mehr machen konnte um anderen
Anforderungen genüge zu tun das müssen
wir ändern und müssen für wir verändern
da wird auch heute einiges noch vom
generalstabschiff zu hören sein das was
wir auch gemacht haben vor ein paar
Monaten angewiesen dass es 2024 eine
Großübung geben soll wie sie schon
jahrelang nicht gegeben hat namens
Schutzschild 24 das Thema wird eine
schutzoperation sein das Ziel dieser
Übung ist dass die militärischen
Kernfähigkeiten der Soldatinnen und
Soldaten durch praktische Anwendung auf
der gefechtstechnischen und taktischen
Ebene zu festigen der Einsatz
stadstoff der Streitkräfte zu evaluieren
und weiterzuentwickeln das wird alle
Waffengattungen umfassen einschließlich
der Luftstreitkräfte und Herr
generalmaier natürlich auch die Miliz
sie findet in den drei Bundesländern
Niederösterreich Steiermark und Kärnten
statt nicht ich glaube dass auch eines
wichtig ist dass in der Masse dann auch
im freien Gelände geübt wird weil ich es
für unabdingbar notwendig halten das
halte dass wir die Präsenz des
Bundesheeres in der Öffentlichkeit wo
auch immer dieses möglich ist dass wir
das
Stärken sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
das Chef des Generalstabs Rudolf
stridinger wird Ihnen heute einiges zum
Aufbauplan 2032 präsentieren wie noch
überzeugt davon dass die anschließenden
Ausführungen insbesondere auch die
Podiumsdiskussion der wehrsprecher ein
mit Sicherheit interessanter und
lehrreicher Nachmittag sein wird mit
ohne Zweifel spannenden Diskussionen das
ist auch gut so wenn man diskutiert und
sich austauscht aber ich glaube das
große Ganze das dürfen wir nicht aus dem
Auge verlieren daher bin ich tatsächlich
wirklich
froh dass uns dieses gelungen ist was
das Budget des österreichischen
Bundesheeres anbelangt die Diskussionen
werden spannend werden am Podium bin
aber überzeugt auch dann beim geselligen
Teil da kann ich dann leider nicht mehr
dabei sein ich bin aber überzeugt davon
dass ich einige von ihnen nebenhalte
wenn bei der Offiziere 10 werde
besonders mit den schweizerkameraden
passiert dass ein ganz besonderer Event
werden die heuer unsere Partner sind ich
glaube dass auch das nach den Jahren der
Pandemie etwas Wichtiges ist sich wieder
in die Augen schauen zu können ist nicht
nur über die Schirme zu tun sondern im
persönlichen Austausch darüber zu
sprechen worum es geht was das
übergeordnete Ziel immer sein muss der
Schutz die Sicherheit unseres Landes
damit wir auch in Zukunft in einem
lebenswerten Österreich und dann in
einem hoffentlich friedlichen Europa
leben können es lebe das österreichische
Bundesheer es lebe die Republik
Österreich ich danke Ihnen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir mit dem Aufbauplan in die 30er Jahre
in die Zukunft blicken machen wir noch
einen kurzen Abstecher in die
Vergangenheit und schauen zurück auf die
vergangenen zehn Jahre und ich darf dazu
dem Generalsekretär des Dachverbandes
und dem Präsidenten der
Offiziersgesellschaft Niederösterreich
Brigitte Fender das Wort
ja sehr geehrte Frau Bundesminister sehr
geehrte Abgeordnete zum Nationalrat sehr
geehrter Herr generalstoffchef sehr
geehrter Herr kornkommandant und Chef
Armee in dem Zusammenhang die Bücher die
Schweizer unteroffiziersverbandes von
der Hans von Dachrand wirklich die
Lektüre unserer Jugend wenn ich das so
sagen darf unsere militärischen Jugend
Werte Generalität liebe kameradenwerte
Damen und Herren vorerst darf ich allen
Anwesenden auch noch mal obwohl schon
der 20 ist ein gutes insbesondere
gesundes neues Jahr wünschen wie bereits
die Frau Bundesministerin gesagt hat
heute vor zehn Jahren exakt heute das
war ein Tag das glaube ich geschneit und
es war irgendwie ein ungutes Wetter hat
sich die Bevölkerung Österreichs in der
damaligen Volksbefragung für die
Beibehaltung der Wehrpflicht entschieden
das hat eine Vorgeschichte gestatten Sie
mir ein bisschen einen Blick zurück
nach Ende des Ost-West-Konflikts Anfang
der 90er Jahre unter dem Minister und
Straßenamt und scheidener wurde das
Bundesheer reduziert gleichzeitig aber
mit modernen Gerät ausgestattet
panzerpaket flugzeugbeschaffung das war
die Zeit der Friedensdividende und der
Situation angemessen und gerechtfertigt
ab 2003 sind wir dann ein bisschen so
auf eine schiefe Ebene gekommen mit
Auflösung von Verbänden Ausscheidung des
Großteils des schweren Waffen
Reduzierung der Infrastruktur
Abschaffung der Wiederholungsübungen
also die Truppenübungen die alle zwei
Jahre stattfinden begründet wurde dies
mit politischen Schlagwörtern wieder
ewige Friede das Ende der Geschichte
bekanntlich ein Zitat des amerikanischen
Politologen prinzipiell aus dem Jahr
Klammer auf er glaubt dass das Ende der
Geschichte gekommen ist möge sich einen
historischen Atlas nehmen einmal mit
Daumen Durchblättern also ganz hat er
nicht recht gehabt deshalb steht auch
zugegeben dieser Begriffe haben in der
Vergangenheit jedoch als Vorwand gedient
und die verteidigungsanstrengungen zu
minimieren nicht nur in Österreich
sondern auch bei vielen anderen
europäischen
Armeen wie gesagt diese Begriffe dienten
als Vorwand
der Höhepunkt dieser Diskussion und
dieser schiefen Ebene war die Forderung
nach Abschaffung der Wehrpflicht
das Bundesheer wäre danach falls es
zustande gekommen wäre
angesichts des unveränderten
verfassungsauftrages zu militärischen
Landesverteidigung das ist ein massiver
innerer Widerspruch nicht mehr in der
Lage gewesen die auch nur ansatzweise zu
erfüllen
ja und dann ist war fast ein Wunder ohne
Unterstützung irgendwelche Institutionen
oder sonstiger Gruppierungen haben sich
im Zuge der Debatte zahlreiche Kameraden
zusammengefunden von verschiedenen
lehrpolitischen Vereine und haben gesagt
das ist der ernst weil wenn das passiert
dann können wir das Bundesheer in der
Zweiten Republik vergessen wenn ich dazu
die sagen darf und sind dafür
eingetreten
was in unserer inhaltlichen Grundlage
nach der Volksbefragung haben wir gesagt
wir werden weitermachen wir werden uns
weiter für die Anliegen der
österreichischen Landesverteidigung
einsetzen haben dann auch ein
Grundsatzprogramm wieder sich für eine
ordentliche Gruppe auch gehört haben uns
als juristische Person organisiert haben
einen Grundsatzprogramm gemacht und aus
dem Jahr 2017 einige Punkte das erste
Förderung der geistigen
Landesverteidigung also das wer Willens
das ist schlicht und einfach der Kern
aller verteidigungsanstrengungen die
auch die Frau Bundesminister so eben
dargelegt hat
beim Personalwesen Bekenntnis zu
wehrpflichtung zu Milizsystem
Erweiterung der tauglichkeitskriterien
Wiedereinführung der
Wiederholungsübungen damals
wehrrechtlich Truppenübungen genannt und
auch Erhöhung des Wehrpflichtigen
Anteils im Verhältnis zum Zivildienst es
erfüllt mich immer mit einer gewissen
Trauer wenn man durch den schönen
Wienerwald fährt und dann vor einer
Dienststelle einer Rettungsorganisation
sieht kommt zum Zivildienst weil
eigentlich nach der Verfassung ist das
ja nur für Menschen die Gewissensgründe
haben Waffengewalt gegen andere
anzuwenden ein Ausflucht um nicht in
gewisses Notstände zu kommen aber nicht
quasi wo man die besseren
Rahmenbedingungen findet ja so
materiellen Ausstattung langjährige
Forderung Erhöhung des Budgets
vollständige Ausrüstung aller
Angehörigen des Bundesheeres mit
Uniformen klingt irgendwie skurril aber
wie es vor nicht allzu langer Zeit haben
die Kameraden diese sechs Monate gemacht
haben und dann in der
Einsatzorganisation beordert waren keine
Uniform gehabt dank des Herrn Generals
ist das bereits abgestellt worden ist
sozusagen auf Schiene also wir haben
jetzt alle haben eine Uniformen reichste
Stadt der Welt also das können wir uns
leisten Gott sei Dank ja und
letztendlich und ist der Kern
ausreichende Ausstattung mit schweren
Waffen weil in europäischen Armeen sind
die schweren Waffen der Kern der
Verteidigungsfähigkeit
ja wie setzen wir das um da war eben die
Idee Schaffung des Tages der Wehrpflicht
und der Grundgedanke war nicht dass wir
hier zurückschauen oder dass wir hier in
irgendeiner Form unsere Verdienste da
hochleben lassen sondern der
Grundgedanke war mit den Ziel des
fortentwickelns des Bundesheeres eine
Dialog mit der Politik zu führen oder zu
versuchen aber wir können sie führen
dankenswerterweise und argumentativ zu
begleiten das war sozusagen der
Grundgedanke wenn ich sie kurz passieren
lassen keine Angst es wird nicht zu lang
2014 hatten wir sozusagen noch im Banne
der
Diskussion um die Wehrpflicht und Beruf
sehr war dann das Thema der Weg zu neuen
Wehrpflicht das war auch eine Broschüre
die damals vom Bundesministerium vom
Landesverteidigung mit zahlreichen
Maßnahmen die eben dort überlegt wurden
herausgegeben wurde und im zweiten Teil
am zweiten Tag der Wehrpflicht hatten
wir erstmals die Möglichkeit mit den
mit den Vertretern
der politischen Parteien
zu kommunizieren und die damaligen
wersprecher bzw ihre Vertreter waren
hier in dem Zusammenhang wenn ich auch
auf den Flatscreen schaue fühlt es mich
mit Trauer dass unser Abgeordneter Otto
Bendel nicht mehr unter uns ist der ein
langjähriger Freund der
Landesverteidigung war und der mit
seinem Initiativantrag im Jahr 2015
Entschließungsantrag im Parlament
sozusagen mit der gesagt hat aufgrund
der Änderung der sicherheitspolitischen
Situation müssen wir eine bessere
budgetäre Ausstattung haben etc
sozusagen diese schiefe Ebene abgeleitet
hat und die Forststraße ist nicht mehr
schief und immer steiler runtergegangen
sondern ist ebener geworden und jetzt
wieder ein bisschen bergauf gegangen
also das ist sehr schade dass er nicht
mehr unter uns wählt
ja was waren aber die inhaltlichen
Forderungen und Punkte in diesen zwei
Sachen dass in diesen zwei Tagen der
Wehrpflicht das erste war Erweiterung
der tauglichkeitsbestimmungen
sozusagen das rollmodel ist der
30-Jährige Marathonläufer der super fit
ist aber zum Bundesheer kann er nicht
gehen das ist sozusagen immer das schöne
Beispiel kennt jeder aus einem
Bekanntenkreis hier ein Dank an die Frau
Bundesministerin und den Herrn
Generalstabschef in einer Aktivität in
den letzten drei Jahren wurde das
umgesetzt die tauglichkeitsbestimmungen
wurden erweitert massiv und wir haben
deswegen mehr Personal einerseits im
Bereich der Wehrpflicht also
Grundwehrdiener und auf der anderen
Seite auch im Bereich des Zivildienstes
der bekanntlich der personelle
Ausstattung der anderen Teilbereiche der
umfassenden Landesverteidigung
sicherstellen soll und letztendlich ist
es auch eine Frage der wer Gerechtigkeit
weil wenn der Anteil der untauglichen zu
groß wird dann kippt sozusagen die
Stimmung im Sinne von wer
Ungerechtigkeit nach dem Motto wieso
muss ich ich zahle auch nicht wenn der
Schweiz universitätssteuer sondern unter
anderem muss also ich muss einrücken und
das machen und andere fährt da werden
ein Studium hoch oder mit seinem
beruflichen Aktivitäten also auch die
lehrgerechtigkeit das ist ein ganz
wichtiger Punkt die zweite Forderung die
wir eigentlich seit am Beginn haben
wieder Einführung der
Wiederholungsübungen also 6 + 2 nämlich
regelmäßige Übungen alle zwei Jahre und
hier eine Bitte an die Politik wir
vertreten diese Forderung seit vielen
vielen Jahren in vielen Bereichen
beruflicher Felder also Sanitäter Ärzte
aber auch Inhaber von Führerscheinen
Berechtigungen
lizenzenpiloten und und alles mögliche
gibt es gesetzliche Pflichten zu
Wiederholung und auffrischungsmaßnahmen
alle zwei Jahre oder alle drei Jahre das
heißt überall dort ist es möglich es
gilt auch der Grundsatz des lebenslangen
Lernens warum gilt dies nicht der
Grundsatz der Fortbildung für
Milizsoldaten ich glaube das sollten
überlegen und hier sollten wir einen
Schritt machen in die richtige Richtung
Dritter Tag der Wehrpflicht
hier sind wir eigentlich sehr gut im
Ziel gelegen Bedrohungen für Österreich
wie gesagt es wird ein Jahr vorher
geplant damals war die migrationskrise
2015 Grad knapp vorbei ein paar Monate
der dem September also 15 begonnen aber
es war noch eine zweite Sache und zwar
das war eben Beginn der Krise im Osten
also 2014 dombas also in der Ukraine
der Vortragenden ja und hier auch eine
inhaltliche weil ich möchte nicht nur
eine Erzählung machen was wir gemacht
haben sondern auch ein inhaltliche
Bewertung und inhaltliche Bewertung war
die in der Zeit der Auflösungen wurde
immer argumentiert mit der zehnjährigen
vorwanzzeit gut das klingt einmal
wunderbar ich habe mich immer gefragt
wie geht das geht jetzt ein rsa-brief
von irgendeinem Staat beim
Außenministerium sagt ab jetzt rüsten
würde auf und ihr müsst irgendwas machen
nein wohl kaum gut also faktische Sachen
faktische Sachen ja dass die Kämpfe im
Osten losgebrochen sind und das waren
eine Kämpfe durchaus von entsprechenden
Dimensionen mit schweren Waffen mit
ganzen Brigaden im dompass das waren ja
nicht nur ein paar kleine Aufständische
mit dem Gewehr in der Hand dass die
losgebrochen sind das war 20 14 der Fall
nur es hat irgendwie glaube ich niemand
die vorwandzeit ernst genommen und sagt
so jetzt müssen wir wieder Verbände
aufstellen etc also das war auch ein
politisches Schlagwort dass man glaube
ich zu sagen irgendwie in die
Textbausteine zurückschieben kann aber
nicht in der aktuellen politischen
Diskussion mehr verwenden muss
Europäische Union fünfter Tag der
Wehrpflicht hier haben wir uns
hier haben wir uns Patron das der dritte
ja vierter Tag der wehrpflichten da
haben wir uns also beim Thema Wirtschaft
und also Wirtschaft und
Landesverteidigung am vierten Tag der
Wehrpflicht 2017 unter anderem die in
uns näher beschäftigt mit der EU
Sicherheitspolitik insbesondere auch mit
den neuen
Finanzierungsinstrumenten der
Europäischen Union sage zum Beispiel
europäische friedensfahrtsität das ist
ein Hauptinstrument das jetzt in der
jetzigen Situation zur Anwendung kommt
und das nächste Jahr beim nächsten
Tag der Wehrpflicht gab es zwei Jubiläen
und zwar
150 Jahre Wehrpflicht in Österreich auch
das ist etwas dem wir gedenken wollten
und 5 Jahre erblich Volksbefragung
ja wir kommen zum Jahr 2019
sechster Tag der Wehrpflicht hier hat
erstmals der damals amtierende
Bundesminister für Landesverteidigung
Minister kunasek und die Ehre gegeben
seiner Anwesenheit also das war der
erste Minister der in einer
Veranstaltung teilgenommen hat und das
Thema war Hybride Bedrohungen wie
widerstandsfähig ist Österreich also man
analysieren in den einzelnen
Teilbereichen nämlich nicht nur
militärisch sondern auch in den zivilen
Teilbereichen
wie lange hat man eigentlich eine
Durchhaltefähigkeit na wie lange kann
das Rote Kreuz Baden durchhalten einen
Tag zwei Tage drei Wochen etc also gibt
es Vorräte an
Betriebsmittel gibt es Vorräte an
Lebensmittel gibt es Ersatzpersonal etc
darauf anschließend haben wir nächstes
Jahr von der inhaltlichen Logik her das
Thema gehabt umfassende
Landesverteidigung die umfassende
Antwort auf moderne Bedrohungen das war
quasi dann die Antwort auf die vorherige
Bedrohungsanalyse und hier hatten wir
erstmals dankenswerterweise die
Gelegenheit dass die Frau Bundesminister
Grußworte uns überbrachte und ihre uns
mit der Ehre ihrer persönlichen
Anwesenheit auszeichnete
Ziel und Vortragende waren die Vertreter
der drei zivilen Teilbereiche der
umfassenden Landesverteidigung ich werde
dann ein bisschen auf einen speziell
noch zu sprechen kommen und hier haben
wir eben ja halt herum diskutiert was es
gibt gut da hat man sehr darüber gedacht
na gut dass das Hobby von älteren Herren
nicht die heute irgendwie so der
Berufslaufbahn haben und die ich noch
verhaftet sind in ullv und deshalb ein
bisschen vor exotisches ja nur zwei
Monate später im März 2020 ist mit der
corona-krise das ganze echt ausgebrochen
und da waren dann genau diese Fragen
nämlich Lebensmittel Bevorratung
Lebensmittel Lenkung lenkungsgesetze die
also das ganze sozusagen auch eine
Verteilung sicherstellen können
Erweiterung der zivilen
sanitätskapazitäten dass man eben die
Betten Zahl in Spitälern nicht nur
gleich lässt sondern auch verdoppeln
oder wenigstens 20% erweitern kann
heranziehunter Zivildiener bitte werden
300.000 zivildieneres Wissen in
Österreich
Franzi unter Zivildiener zu einem
außerordentlichen Zivildienst all das
war plötzlich hochaktuell also man sieht
diese Sachen mit denen wir uns
beschäftigen sie nicht ausschließlich
Theorie graue Theorie sondern sie werden
man muss sagen leider weil es ja
krisenvorsorgen sind hochaktuell nur man
muss die vorsorgen tätigen
in
das ist hatten wir die Möglichkeit einen
Blick über die Grenzen zu werfen das
Thema war Sicherheitspolitik 2021 sind
unsere Antworten noch zeitgemäß nach
Grußworten das ist ein Bundespräsidenten
wurden durch Referate der
verteidigungsadresse von Schweden und
Schweiz und der Schweiz ein Blick auf
die verteidigungsanstrengung
vergleichbarer Staaten geworfen der
Direktor für Sicherheitspolitik und der
normale Generalsekretär im
Bundesministerium für Landesverteidigung
dr Kraml zeigte die Ableitungen für
Österreich und insbesondere auch die
europäische Dimension aus
hier eine geschlussfolgerungen auf den
damaligen Statements der Vertreter der
ist von Schweden und der Schweiz
der Kern meine sehr geehrten Damen und
Herren jeder Armee sind die schweren
Waffen
Fliegerabwehr Kampf und Jagdpanzer
Luftfahrzeuge das ist der Kern deshalb
liegt auch das Schwergewicht der
Neuerungen und Beschaffungen anderer
Armeen genau in diesem Bereichen zur
Situation in Österreich noch einmal ein
kurzer Blick zurück in diesen Zeiten der
Auflösung ab 2003 wurde das
österreichische Bundesheer hemmungslos
gerade im Bereich der schweren Waffen
reduziert ich nehme nur die Ostregion
also die Länder Niederösterreich Wien
und Burgenland
wir hatten 180 Kampf und Jagdpanzer ich
erspare es allen die Bataillonen
Kompanien aufzuzählen heute null wir
hatten 190 fliegergeschütze in diesem
Raum heute null das heißt das ist
überzogen diese Form der Auflösung und
der Dachverband tritt und trat immer für
eine angemessene Ausstattung der
Verbände des Bundesheeres auf wann wenn
nicht jetzt ist Zeit dafür
2022 migration
als Waffe nach großarten des Herrn
Bundeskanzlers legten die Botschaft um
ganz genau zu sehen die Botschaft
erinnern von
Litauen Lettland und Polen
eindrucksvollender Widerstandswillen
ihrer Länder gegen die von Weißrussland
geförderte illegale Migration da
auch hier einige Bemerkungen
das Bundesheer stellt seit 1991 auf
Anforderung des Innenministeriums das ja
für den
grenzraumüberwachung und Schutz und und
Kontrolle und so weiter zuständig ist
massiv Truppen an der Süd- und Ostgrenze
diese nicht militärisch ausgebildeten
Soldaten also Grundwehrdiener fehlen in
der Einsatz Organisation das ist genau
das was da unser Herr Präsident gesagt
hat wenn man dann über seine gar nicht
ausgebildet ja richtig weil ich war eben
an der Grenze und habe dort
Assistenzeinsatz gemacht dennoch obwohl
wir so eine massiven Aufwand tätigen als
Republik Österreich
nimmt die illegale und bitte illegales
bekanntlich die rechtswidrige migration
immer mehr zu letztes Jahr bekanntlich
über 100.000 oder je nach Tageszeitung
die man liest halt 100 oder 110.000 ist
auch egal
es ist mir und vielen anderen
unverständlich warum es in Österreich
nicht möglich ist die illegale Migration
in den Griff zu bekommen wie so schön
heißt oder zumindest substantiell zu
reduzieren
auf eine eu-lösung zu verweisen ist
nicht besonders zielführend und zwar aus
dem Grund Schengen Schutz der
Außengrenzen funktioniert das nein sonst
hätten wir nicht diese 100.000 illegalen
gehabt was ist mit den Dublin Abkommen
wonach bereits wonach im ersten Staat im
ersten EU-Staat wo eben ein ein Migrant
hineinkommt und das Wort Asyl sagt einen
entsprechendes Verfahren abzuführen ist
funktioniert auch nicht das heißt immer
nur sagen ja die EU soll irgendwelche
Lösungen machen das ist keine sinnvolle
Vorgangsweise der Kern des Problems und
ich weiß dass das vielleicht zur
Diskussionen führen wird ist der Auftrag
an die zuständigen Organe statt die
illegalen an der Grenze zu sagen in
Empfang zu nehmen und dann also nach
Eisenstadt zu führen dort fühlen sie
Zetteln aus und kriegt einen
farbgutschein nach rechts Traiskirchen
und sind heute in Österreich angekommen
was er nett ist aber heute auf die Dauer
ein Problem wäre die Zurückweisung an
der Grenze so ein böses Wort nur im
Fremdenpolizei gesetzt
steht drinnen dass die Organe die
Pflicht haben jemand der keinen Bass und
kein Visum hat zurückzuweisen geltendes
Recht
ja daher Abgeordnete das habe ich
natürlich sofort im nächsten Absatz
verpackt auch bei einem behaupteten
Asylgrund gibt es mittlerweile Judikatur
das Europäischen Gerichtshof für
Menschenrechte wonach ist die
Zurückweisung unter bestimmten Umständen
möglich ist falls es dann noch
rechtliche Zweifel gibt gibt es das
Zauberwort legislativmaßnahme was wir ja
tagtäglich machen das heißt man kann
sowohl im innerstaatlichen Recht als
auch bei internationalen Abkommen
entsprechende Änderungen vornehmen nur
angehen muss man weil bitte wir können
dieses Problem seit 1991 also es wäre
Zeit dass man schon langsam die Sache
annimmt weil und hier noch ein bisschen
zu
finanziellenkomponente diejenigen die
also entweder bei illegale Migration das
irgendwie verharmlosen werden sich
entscheiden müssen
Sozialstaat oder offene Grenzen beides
gleichzeitig wird auf längere Zeit nicht
finanzierbar sein
[Applaus]
so wir mit unseren Forderungen und
Vorstellungen die ich eingangs
geschildert habe kann man sagen okay ist
eine Meinung aber es gibt ja auch die
Realität und darum möchte ich noch einen
kleinen Reality-Check wie du so schön
auf neudeutsch heißt machen das Jahr
2022 brachte eine Zeitenwende mit sich
nämlich aus dem seit 2014 spielenden
Konflikt im Osten wurde eben mit der
russischen Invasion ein aktueller
sogenannter international bewaffneter
Konflikt weil Krieger gibt es
bekanntlich nicht nur diesen abgelöst
worden durch das Wort international
bewaffnet
daraus ergeben sich einige inhaltliche
Schlussfolgerungen erste
Schlussfolgerung der wer Wille ist der
Kern aller verteidigungsanstrengungen in
Österreich heißt das geistige
Landesverteidigung und ist
kompetenzmäßig im Unterrichtsministerium
zugeordnet dazu gibt es einige Eckdaten
modernen Management sollen wir immer
Benchmarks und Eckdaten und sowas machen
und zwar das ist 48 11 21
48 die Verfassungsbestimmung ist 1975 in
der Verfassung verankert worden es waren
also 48 Jahre Zeit die entsprechenden
Maßnahmen zu ergreifen na das ist ja
schon eine gewisse Zeit 11 das Budget
dieses Jahr ist für das
Bildungsministerium beträgt rund 11
Milliarden Euro das ist eine Menge Geld
und da muss auch ein bisschen Geld da
sein dass man auch den Tätigkeitsbereich
geistige Landesverteidigung aber
arbeitet und 21 nach einem
internationalen Ranking das also im
Internet abrufbar ist sind nur 21% der
Österreicher bereit ihr Land mit der
Waffe in der Hand zu verteidigen oder
wie gesagt 48 11 21 gut da ist das
Bildungsministerium ist dafür vielleicht
noch hinzufügen wenn man das ganze etwas
schulischer Sicht betrachtet jeder weiß
dass Kinder Enkelkinder lichten Neffen
wenn man für eine Aufgabe von 100
möglichen Punkten nur 21 erreicht hat
ist das wohl kein sehr gut er das
Gegenteil
zweite Schlussfolgerung ohne Wehrpflicht
und hohe heerstärke ist keine effektive
Verteidigung möglich einerseits das
gesamte Staatsgebiet kann nicht
abgedeckt werden das ist die räumliche
Dimension zweitens man kann hat auch
keine Durchhaltefähigkeit also über
einen längeren Zeitraum die
verteidigungsanstrengungen aufrecht zu
erhalten das ist die zeitliche Dimension
sozusagen die Tiefe die Tiefe des Raumes
ist das eine und die Tiefe der Zeit
darauf aufbauend sind doch mehrere
europäische Länder wieder dazu
übergegangen von Beruf sehr zur
Wehrpflicht überzugehen Litauen 2008
abgeschafft 20 15 eingeführt
Lettland 2007 abgeschafft 2022
eingeführt Schweden 2010 ausgesetzt war
auf einer Dienstreise dort das war sehr
interessant also alles Mini sehr Mini
und sie haben nicht keine Freude gehabt
2017 eingeführt auch in Deutschland gibt
es bereits stimmen die zurück zu
Wehrpflicht an diskutieren zum Beispiel
Eva Högl werbeauftragte des Deutschen
Bundestages nannte die Aussicht
Aussetzung der Wehrpflicht einen
Riesenfehler ja und die letzten drei
schlussfolger und kurz noch
zusammengefasst militärisch liegt das
Schwergewicht bei schweren Waffen ohne
effektive Ausbildung Stichwort das was
ich vorhin gesagt hat ist eben eine
effektive Einsatz nicht möglich und ohne
Bevorratung sowohl im militärischen als
auch zivilen Bereich hat ein Staat keine
Durchhaltefähigkeit in einer Krise das
haben wir gerade auch in der
corona-krise erlebt abschließend möchte
ich die erfreuliche Perspektive darlegen
die erfreuliche Perspektive ist wir als
wehrpolitische Verbände gratulieren zu
den budget-32
die mehrjährigen der mehrjährige
Budgetplan und das
landesverteilungsfinanzierungsgesetz
werden es ermöglichen mittelfristige
Planungen umzusetzen wir freuen uns
schon auf das Referat des Herrn
generalstoffchefs und noch eine Bitte an
die wehrsprecher
unterstützen Sie diesen Aufbauplan
bilden sie einen nationalen Konsens und
stellen sie in Sachen
Verteidigungspolitik das gemeinsame vor
das Trennende
[Applaus]
wir als lehrpolitische Vereine werden
diesen Wiederaufbau mit aller Kraft
unterstützen sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren ich darf mich für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit sehr herzlich bedanken
dankeschön
[Applaus]
[Musik]
herzlichen Dank an das lesequintett der
Gardemusik und das Stichwort Aufbauplan
2032 wurde bereits mehrfach erwähnt und
wir freuen uns sehr dass sich der Chef
des Generalstab sehr general Rudolf
Schmidinger bereit erklärt hat die
militärstrategischen Aspekte dieses
Planes darzustellen ja general lieber
Rudi der Florian
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Abgeordnete Liebe
militärgeistlichkeit lieber
amtskameradaus
der Schweizerischen Eidgenossenschaft
Liebe Kommandanten und
Dienststellenleiter des
Bundesministeriums für
Landesverteidigung und des
österreichischen Bundesheeres sehr
geehrte Generalität des Ruhestandes
meine sehr verehrten Damen und Herren
lieber Vorsitzender zunächst mal
herzlichen Dank dafür die Möglichkeit zu
haben hier nach neun Jahren beim ersten
Mal so rechnen also nicht nach zehn
Jahren vor zehn Jahren haben abgestimmt
hier stehen zu dürfen damals als
Militärkommandant von Niederösterreich
und jetzt in der jetzigen Funktion
und ich freue mich darüber dass das Wort
militärstrategische Ebene
so betontet und im Vordergrund steht ich
würde also keine Einkaufsliste Vorlesen
was der Aufbauplan des österreichischen
Bundesheeres 2032 beinhaltet weil das
kann es nicht gewesen sein sondern auch
ich möchte und wenn dieses Verständnis
zu erzeugen was wir überhaupt
stattfindet und warum vor allem in der
Vergangenheit was passiert ist und wo
wir jetzt hingehen
auch ein bisschen zurückschauen knapp 20
Jahre wir hatten eine
bundesheerreformkommission unter Zilk
und ein Projekt BH 2010 und damals wurde
das österreichische Bundesheer
ausgerichtet auf
den Auslandseinsatz
Regale starke rahmenverbände für den
Auslandseinsatz im Inland bereitstellen
und ablösefähig über einen längeren
Zeitraum sicherstellen
das war das Ziel und das Abfallprodukt
dessen war die österreichische
Landesverteidigung im Inland
und deswegen gab es auch nie eine
Vollausstattung insbesondere für die
Miliz nicht weil das nicht notwendig war
sondern geschaut aus dem präsenten her
mit Auffüllung aus der Miliz je nach
Freiwilligkeit für den Auslandseinsatz
ist das ja notwendig einfach zu schauen
was man dazu sagen bringt noch dazu ohne
wirkliche nationale Verpflichtung eine
gewisse Größenordnung zusammenzubringen
sondern das was man zusammenbricht das
hat man und nicht mehr
dessen muss man sich sehr bewusst sein
wenn man die weiteren Schritte die dann
in den Folgejahren passiert sind auch
verstehen will
zweiter Aspekt Neutralität wir haben das
Bundesheer immer so in den Fähigkeiten
behalten dass wir von jedem immer
irgendetwas haben wir haben es dann
rekonstruktionskern bezeichnet aber wir
haben nicht Waffengattungen aufgegeben
auch ein ganz ein wichtiger Aspekt
nämlich dass wir jetzt in einer
Situation sind wo wir nicht irgendetwas
komplett neu aufbauen müssen sondern auf
einen bestehenden weiter aufbauen können
jedenfalls ist es bergab gegangen mit
dem Bundesheer aus ganz vielen Gründen
die möchte ich nicht erläutern und dann
wurde noch dazu die Wehrpflicht in Frage
gestellt aus eher rein politischen
Gründen jedenfalls nicht aus
inhaltlichen und ehrlich gesagt muss man
schon dazu sagen dass wir uns wirklich
gerettet hat war auch der Zivildienst
ich kann das bestätigen weil ich habe
das erlebt
dann kam es zu einer Verschärfung der
Lage
Euro im europäischen Kontext oder auch
weltweit gesehen die aber nicht wirklich
realisiert worden ist
man hat das nicht zu ernst genommen dass
die Krim der besetzt wird und so das war
eher so weit weg
und dann
haben wir
im Jahr 2021 eine Entscheidung getroffen
die sehr weit vorausschauend war wie
haben wir uns damals gar nicht bewusst
waren wir haben gesagt okay wir ändern
das
streitkräfteprofil des österreichischen
Bundesheeres wir wechseln
wir sagen nicht mehr der Auslandseinsatz
ist die primäre Aufgabe des Bundesheeres
sondern die militärische
Landesverteidigung ist die Hauptaufgabe
und diese sogenannte streitkräfteprofil
unser her ist tatsächlich eine völlige
Verdrehung der Richtung um 180 Grad und
dem was wir vorher gemacht haben zudem
was 2021 fixiert und beschlossen wurde
und was aus meiner Sicht auch selbst in
unseren militärischen Köpfen noch nicht
wirklich angekommen ist es ist ein
weiter Weg so eine 180 Grad Drehung zu
tun sie ist aber entscheidend und vor
allem eines seit der Zeitenwende ist es
völlig klar dass diese Entscheidung die
richtige war
eines ist aber auch immer klar gewesen
die schutzoperation ist das höchste
ambitionsniveau für die militärische
Landesverteidigung Österreichs die
schutzoperation und nicht die
abwehr-operation und da ist er
deutlicher Unterschied
wenn wir in die Richtung kommen müssen
von einer abwehroperation reden zu
können dann ist der Aufbauplan 2032 zwar
in erster Ansatz aber völlig
unzureichend das wissen wir alle
was hat uns die Zeitenwende gebracht
eine budget-entwicklung die ist im
österreichischen Bundesheer jedenfalls
in der Zweiten Republik aber
wahrscheinlich auch historisch
zurückgesehen außer in Kriegszeiten nie
gegeben hat
so eine Entwicklung ist etwas
Außergewöhnliches und
wir als Militärs sind der politischen
Führung sehr dankbar und vor allem den
Parlament dass das auch so beschlossen
hat dass dieser Weg eingeschlagen wurde
und zwar in dreifacher Hinsicht ein
moderner Anstieg mit dem heurigen Budget
eine weitere moderate aber deutliche
Erhöhung in den nächsten Jahren und das
wichtigste dabei ist die zehn
jahresperspektive mit dem
landesverteidigungsfinanzierungsgesetz
das uns die Planungstiefe ermöglicht und
wir wissen alle dass man
einjährig überhaupt nicht planen kann
bei Militär und vierjährig ist auch zu
wenig
und die Entwicklung ist eine erhebliche
wenn wir ausgehend von 2022 im Endeffekt
dann beinahe zu einer Verdopplung des
wehrbudgets kommen und innerhalb von
zehn Jahren immerhin nur für den
Investitionsbereich über 16 Milliarden
Euro zur Verfügung haben werden
das ist viel Geld
und ich diskutiere nicht und Konzept
Prozentsätze es ist unsere Aufgabe ist
es Geld ordnungsgemäß richtig und dem
Parlament und dem Steuerzahler
verpflichtet korrekt einzusetzen
die Frage
was wir damit machen
das ist ein drei große Kategorien
eingeteilt
dass was wir wollen was der Soldat
unmittelbar spüren muss ist dass wir für
ihn seine persönlichen Schutz und
seinlich persönlichen Fähigkeiten auf
dem Gefechtsfeld zu überleben deutlich
steigern die gesamte Schutzausrüstung
die gesamte Kommunikationsausrüstung
alles dies seine Waffen
modernisieren dafür sorgen und wir sehen
sie auch in der Ukraine dass es ganz
zweckmäßig ist wenn einfache Soldaten
wirkt Mittel haben die hochkomplexe
Systeme in der Lage sind auf in der Luft
und auf dem Boden entsprechend zu
bekämpfen
also der einzelne Soldat muss davon
profitieren können
der zweite Teil ist
die Mobilität
wir sind
ziemlich am Boden was die Beweglichkeit
betrifft allein schon die normale
Beweglichkeit ist nicht einfach aber es
hilft uns nicht und ich möchte deutlich
feststellen dass wir kein
Nachfolgeprodukt eines pinzgauers
brauchen
weil wir werden nicht mehr eine Gruppe
eine Jägergruppe auf einen Pinzgauer
setzen und damit auf den Gefechtsfeld
herumfahren das macht man heutzutage
nicht sondern braucht man braucht etwas
worunter man zumindest ein bisschen ist
und daher geht es darum eine geschützte
Mobilität für die Soldaten
sicherzustellen das wird keine
Vollausstattung sein können das hat auch
sonst niemand aber zumindest in einem
Prozentsatz dass man entsprechend seine
Soldaten und Soldatinnen ordnungsgemäß
geschützt
auf den Gefechtsfeld bewegen kann
und gerade in einer schutzoperation ist
der Feind immer rundum der hat keine
Richtung und deswegen ist dort in jede
Richtung vorne und hinten
Mobilität in der Luft
die Frau Bundesministerin hat gesagt wir
haben den ersten Schritt getan und das
ist ein ganz ganz wesentlicher Schritt
was die luftscheitkräfte Mobilität in
der Luft betrifft wir werden das
fortsetzen und wenn die Arbeit 212
herauszunehmen sein werden dann werden
wir die Black Hawk Staffel entsprechend
verstärken so dass das was wir uns
vornehmen eine gewisse Menge von Truppe
geschlossen irgendwohin zu fliegen und
das auch entsprechend aus dem Luftraum
zu schützen dazu in der Lage sein werden
wir werden tc130 ersetzen diesen Prozess
haben wir eingeleitet und das wird im
Laufe der zweiten Hälfte der 20er Jahre
zu erledigen sein mit der Zielrichtung
eines strategischen luftransportraum in
einer vergleichbaren Größenordnung auch
weiter zu haben
wir werden die Eurofighter weiter
fliegen selbstverständlich
wahrscheinlich bis zum Lebensende
weil der Ersatz relativ teuer ist wie
wir wissen aber vielleicht gelingt es
uns auch die Ausbildung im Endeffekt
dann wieder selbst zu machen die Anzahl
der Doppelsitze dafür ist sehr
überschaubar und wenn dann ein
Trainingsflugzeug noch dazu kommt auch
das ist etwas was wir derzeit im Auge
haben dann werden wir in der Lage sein
die gesamte Pilotenausbildung bei uns zu
machen und
wer weiß wie viel man an wie viele ein
euroväter Pilot kostet der wird dann
wissen dass es zweckmäßig ist zumindest
diese Kosten in Österreich zu lassen
ein
entscheidender Punkt der wirklich
wo wir uns in einer Situation befinden
die wirklich bedenklich ist ist die
Fliegerabwehr also die bodengebundene
Luftabwehr das ist eine mittlere
Katastrophe wir sind das wäre
vergleichbar als wenn das Bundesland der
Lage ist eine Kaserne mehr oder weniger
zu verteidigen das bringen wir derzeit
mit den verfügbaren fliegerabwehrmitteln
zusammen und auch die sind ideale
gekommen was uns dazu zwingt sowohl die
Mistral als auch die 3,5 cm Welle kann
einer entsprechenden
Lebenszeitverlängerung
zuzuführen aber das kann es nicht
gewesen sein und wenn die Frau
Bundesministerin klar und deutlich sagt
wir wollen auch am europäischen
sky-schild teilnehmen
und die vier Punkte die vier Buchstaben
NATO werden in den Hintergrund gedrückt
und wir sind diejenigen die entscheiden
wann bei uns geschossen wird das ist das
entscheidende dabei dann werden wir uns
daran beteiligen und bei der
Fliegerabwehr mittlerer Reichweite wird
das dann schon möglich sein
nicht im Aufbauplan enthalten sind
darüber befindliche Systeme die müssten
gegebenenfalls zukommen
und dann die Qualität zu haben wie die
Schweiz Deutschland und sonstige
Nachbarstaaten
ein wesentlicher Bereich ist die
Herstellung der
Verteidigungsfähigkeit des Bundesheeres
im Sinne von Resilienz
wir machen das oft mit dem Schlagwort
Blackout Vorsorge also Herstellen einer
Infrastruktur denn die Kasernen werden
in Zukunft unsere Stützpunkte sein von
dem aus die militärischen Operationen zu
führen sein werden
Infrastruktur entsprechend Härten die
Infrastruktur für einen bestimmten
Zeitraum entsprechend autark gestalten
das fand bei der Lebensmittelversorgung
an und hört bei der Munitionsversorgung
auf weil da schauen wir auch so rein
dass es so wirklich
nicht unbedingt
erhoffen Munition verfügbar ist also
hier wird auch einiges zu tun sein und
das unter dem Gesichtspunkt der
Nachhaltigkeit und wir haben nicht
umsonst uns auch in diesem Sinne einer
Ökologisierung des Bundesheeres
verschrieben
und wenn es früher darum ging für den
Auslandseinsatz Truppen zur Verfügung zu
stellen war die Größenordnung von 55.000
nicht wirklich ein Thema
jetzt ist das etwas anderes weil eines
ist klar derzeit ist der Rahmen 55.000
wir werden diesen Rahmen
derzeit aufrecht erhalten und jetzt
alles ausrüsten was notwendig ist wir
wissen aber dass für eine
komplette Aufgabenerfüllung selbst unter
dem Prinzip von schutzoperationen in
Österreich ist wahrscheinlich zu wenig
sein wird aber Priorität 1 ist einmal
bei den 55.000 zu bleiben und dort eine
vernünftige Ausstattung insgesamt des
Bundesheeres herzustellen und daher habe
ich
abschließend gesagt im Wesentlichen für
das heurige A3 persönliche Schwerpunkte
die natürlich dann auch für den
Generalstab gelten und für die mir
zugeordneten und darüber hinaus auch
fürs BMLV es geht darum dass heurige
Budget vollständig auszunutzen wir
hatten voriges Jahr eine Budget Erfolg
von 99,94 Prozent das hätte ich gern
dieses Jahr auch weil eines ist klar
alles was wir nicht so anbringen ist
vorbei ist weg
und meine persönliche Verantwortung
liegt darin dafür zu sorgen dass das was
zur Verfügung gestellt wird und da muss
ich sagen die Hausaufgaben sind seit aus
der Politik gemacht jetzt vom Militär
entsprechend umgesetzt wird daher Punkt
2 müssen die planerischen und die
bereits stellungs- und
beschaffungsgrundlagen die wir brauchen
um den Aufbauplan 2032 tatsächlich zu
erfüllen heuer erledigt sein das zeigen
uns heuer fertig sein weil die heurigen
knapp 700 Millionen zusätzlich das
bringen wir schon runter aber jetzt
müssen Verträge gemacht werden damit in
weiterer Folge deutliche Budgetmittel
die uns zuwachsen auch ordnungsgemäß da
braucht und verbraucht und vor allem
sinnvoll genutzt werden können
und der wohl wichtigste Bereich und ich
sage ganz bewusst der wichtigste ist die
Frage des Personals
wir haben durch die Pandemie aber auch
durch die
Einsatzbelastung zur Bekämpfung der
Migration der illegalen Migration
einfach unseren Bogen überspannt und
zwar deutlich überspannt
woran stellen wir das Fest
wir verlieren ausgebildetes junges und
offizierskaterpersonal
wir sind nicht in der Lage unsere
kader-präsenzeinheiten so zu befüllen
wie wir sie bräuchten wir müssen daher
vermehrt kaderpräsenzeinheiten zusammen
stoppen und ihnen Auslandseinsatz
schicken die Leute den Leuten reicht es
mit der Zeit
dann kommt noch dazu dass wir durch die
assistenzleistung für die Migration
leider Gottes nach wie vor
grundverdiener verwenden müssen die wir
eigentlich für Miliz ausbilden sollten
und so kommen wir nicht weiter und dann
ist natürlich der Inlandseinsatz vor
allem auch für die Miliz und da trägt
die Milizen immerhin über 50% eine tolle
Leistung
doch etwas attraktiver als vielleicht
der Auslandseinsatz und die gehen uns im
Auslandseinsatz ab und im
Auslandseinsatz ist alles freiwillig und
das erzeugt auch Probleme bei der
Aufbringung des derzeit eben mit
ungefähr 800 überschaubaren
Auslandseinsatz Engagement das heißt die
personelle Situation des Bundesheeres
ist wirklich angespannt
und jetzt haben wir ein Geld und mit dem
wollen wir schauen dass wir
entsprechende Infrastruktur Ausrüstung
Bewaffnung entsprechend sicherstellen
dann brauchen wir auch das richtige
Personal dafür
in zu kommt die Frage der Miliz wir
wissen dass es eine entsprechende
Herausforderung
dazu ein klares Wort von meiner Seite
wir haben
attraktivierungsmaßnahmen eingeleitet
und wir wollen jetzt einmal überprüfen
in welcher in welchem Ausmaß wir in der
Lage sind dass die tatsächlich zum
Greifen kommen denn eines habe ich
zumindest auch persönliche Erfahrung und
da werden wir wahrscheinlich viele
zustimmen festgestellt wenn es möglich
ist mit Freiwilligkeit im Sinne von
freiwilliger Verpflichtung unseren Miliz
Rahmen halbwegs zu befüllen dann ist es
besser als die Leute zu zwingen das ist
jedenfalls richtig wenn das nicht geht
muss man sich andere Gedanken machen
aber von vornherein gleich um zu
schwenken das ist eine andere Sache
daher lasst uns das einmal probieren es
ist unsere Aufgabe dafür zu sorgen die
milzverbände auf diese Art und Weise zu
befüllen das ist zunächst einmal die
Zielsetzung
und in diesem Sinne
ersuche ich um folgendes bitte nicht
jammern dass wir so wenig Geld kriegen
es ist nicht zu wenig
lassen wir
das
realisieren wozu wir in der Lage sein
werden das wird zumindest einmal für die
derzeitige Situation in der unsere
Regierungs befinden in einem ersten
Schritt in den nächsten zehn Jahren
ausreichend sein herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
[Musik]
nochmals herzlichen Dank an das Garde
Quintett aber vor allem auch ganz
herzlichen Dank an den Generalstabschef
für seine Ausführungen und er hat ja
sozusagen zwei
Säulen oder zwei Pfeiler angesprochen
das Material und das Personal und über
diese beiden Themenstellungen werden wir
nunmehr auch in der Diskussion oder in
der Veränderung mit den wersprechern
einsteigen
ans Publikum gerichtet die Information
die fünf Herren sind vorinformiert was
ich sie fragen werde nein
e-mail-leser wissen manchmal
und die erste Runde zielt auf die
materielle Ebene ab und
ja gerade unter stockmüller sie haben
jetzt ein paar Augenblicke Zeit sich ein
zu schwingen denn wir beginnen mit der
Opposition und zwar mit dem Abgeordneten
Heuers von den Neos und die
Fragestellung lautet was jetzt skizziert
wurde an materieller Entwicklung an
Langfristigkeit wie schätzen Sie das ein
im Sinne von Treffsicherheit im Sinne
von
ist das ausreichend ist das treffsicher
inwieweit ist nach ihrer politischen
Einschätzung jetzt ist eine alle jetzt
nicht die Militärexperten im engeren
Sinne aber aus der politischen
Einschätzung heraus sehen sie da die
Chance dass diese Hauptaufgabe
militärische Landesverteidigung
entsprechend dem Verfassungsauftrag
wahrgenommen werden kann wir sind in der
Zeit ein bisschen Motor fortgeschritten
als ursprünglich geplant daher würde ich
Sie bitten Ihre Antworten auch
entsprechend kürzer zu fassen dankeschön
das ist immer für die Politiker der
größte Herausforderung sich kurz zu
fassen
viel lernen wir das selten
vielleicht also danke einmal für die
Einladung und ich finde das ja
mittlerweile eine gewisse Tradition auch
für uns wersprecher hat und das ist
glaube ich auch immer so ein bisschen
ein wehrpolitischer Jahresauftakt
mittlerweile das was ich sehr positiv
finde ich will jetzt kein jetzt viele
Details sind glaube ich je präsentiert
worden vom Herrn general die glaube ich
sehr wichtig und spannend sind ich
glaube aber die Frage ist eine die sie
auch gestellt haben ist das genug
individuelle die Frage die wir uns so
vorstellen müssen ist was ist die
Herausforderung was ist das konkrete
Ziel es wurde angesprochen vorher es
geht hier auch darum dass die
wehrsprecher und die Parteien
zusammenarbeiten ich glaube das ist
momentan so sehr der Fall wie selten
zuvor zumindest in meiner Wahrnehmung
und das ist etwas sehr Positives weil
ich glaube es eint alle wer Sprecher in
ihrer Funktion und in ihrer Rolle auch
in den einzelnen Parteien dass sie hier
dieses Ziel das österreichische
bundesheeran zu bringen am ernst meinen
und das hier auch wirklich eine gute
Zusammenarbeit auf unserer Ebene besteht
die Frage ist nur warum nützen wir diese
Situation die wir aktuell haben nicht um
auch diese Basis nämlich was ist das
Ziel wohin wollen wir das
österreichische Bundesheer bringen auf
einen parteiübergreifenden eine
parteiübergreifende Plattform zu stellen
und hier beispielsweise die USA zu
nehmen und auch anzupassen an die
aktuellen Sicherheitslage die sich und
das wurde ja auch vorher in den
Vorträgen sehr schön präsentiert massiv
verändert hat das muss ich ihnen nicht
erklären dass sich das in den letzten 10
Jahren verändert hat und auch davor
schon das heißt das ist glaube ich die
eine Sache die zweite Sache die wir und
es wurde von ihnen auch Erbringer dir
sehr viel darüber gesprochen über das
Thema geistige Landesverteidigung ich
glaube wir haben momentan eine Situation
wo der Bevölkerung so bewusst ist wie
selten zuvor was Krieg was sicherheit
bedeutet und das ist eine einzigartige
Situation die wir hoffentlich in dieser
Form nicht mehr oft erleben werden
müssen das führt auch dazu dass
natürlich der politische Druck viel
stärker ist hier auch Schritte für das
österreichische Bundesheer zu machen nur
was tun wir wenn diese Situation nicht
mehr da ist mit dem österreichischen
Bundesheer wir tun jetzt investieren und
setzen jetzt Schritte und deswegen
glaube ich ist es jetzt auch wichtig das
Thema geistige Landesverteidigung
anzugehen weil sie haben Zitate
vorgelesen aus den Foren und das sieht
man dass die geistige Landesverteidigung
bei der Bevölkerung in vielen Bereichen
nicht angeboten angekommen ist und ich
glaube dass die geistige
Landesverteidigung in diesen Zeiten des
Aufbauens nicht geschätzt werden darf
die mitzudenken und auch hier stärker
wieder in den Fokus zu rücken damit das
Bewusstsein in der Bevölkerung für
Sicherheit da ist damit das Bewusstsein
in der Bevölkerung auch für eine gute
Ausstattung egal ob personell und an
welchem Bereich auch immer für das
österreichische Bundesheer da ist und
ich glaube wir dürfen nicht den Fehler
machen und jetzt zurückzulehnen und
sagen funktioniert gerade gut sondern
wir müssen diese Hausaufgaben auch auf
anderen Ebene machen neben dem
beschaffungsdämmen die ohne Zweifels
notwendig sind wenn der Stallinger
Bericht wurde angesprochen der zeigt das
ja eh klar wo hier die Dinge zu tun sind
herzlichen Dank
[Applaus]
darf gleich weitergeben an den Vertreter
der FPÖ
Dankeschön also vorweg möchte ich eines
klarstellen und zwar das ist gut ist
dass das Bundesheer jetzt mehr Geld
bekommt und dass ich auch den Aufbauplan
2032 keinesfalls für verkehrt halte
leider bleibt aber festzustellen dass es
in Österreich immer so ist dass immer
zuerst irgendetwas tragisches passieren
muss bevor die Politik ist bereit ist
hier Geld in die Sicherheit zu
investieren ihre Männer gut
landeslawinen Unglück in Galtür im Jahr
1999 dass der Anlass war dass wir dann
Gott sei Dank hier black Hop
Hubschrauber angeschafft haben und jetzt
hat es leider einen Krieg in Europa
gebraucht um es zu schaffen dass wir
eine signifikante budgetherhöhung in
Österreich bekommen das ist stimmt nicht
traurig und bedenklich dass es eben
immer so einen Anfall benötigt und wir
nicht vorausschauend und
verantwortungsbewusst hier in unsere
Sicherheit investieren können
wenn sie aber fragen ob das Bundesheer
damit auf etwaige einsatzaufgaben
ausreichend vorbereitet sein wird und ob
es damit seinen Auftrag der
militärischen Landesverteidigung
erfüllen wird können dann muss ich das
hiermit das meiner Sicht mit einem
klaren Nein beantworten zum einen ist
die materielle Ausstattung nur eine
Seite der Medaille diese reicht nicht
wenn auf der anderen Seite dann das
Personal fehlt und mit dieser Ausrüstung
auch entsprechend in den Einsatz gehen
zu können und das Personalproblem das
ist mindestens so wichtig wie die
finanzielle Ausstattung und wir haben
sowohl bei den Berufssoldaten als auch
bei den milzsoldaten enorme
Personalprobleme die sich in den
nächsten Jahren noch ganz massiv
verschärfen werden und wenn man jetzt
viel Geld her nimmt und das in den
falschen System schüttet dann freut es
die zwar die noch verbliebenen Soldaten
weil sie mehr Ausrüstung bekommen aber
eine militärische Landes Bewegung ist
damit allein noch nicht zu machen und um
militärische Landesverteidigung leisten
zu können brauchen wir wieder ein
Bundesheer das nach dem Miliz Prinzip
eingerichtet ist so wie das ja
eigentlich unsere Bundesverfassung auch
vorführen vorgeben würde und für eine
militärische Landesverteidigung wie ich
sie verstehe es war die heute vom
kleinen generalstoffchef schon kurz
angesprochen reicht ein Mobil
machensrahmen von 55.000 Mann zum einen
nicht aus und zum anderen reicht auch
eine ich sage mal eine scheinmilizen
nicht aus die auf befristet beorderte in
einem großen Ausmaß setzt und ich
verstehe unter militärischer
Landesverteidigung eben mehr als diese
schutzoperation sondern darunter
verstehe ich sehr wohl auch eine Abwehr
Operation also einen Verteidigungsfall
gegen konventionelle Kräfte und das ist
etwas was die jetzige Regierung nicht
einmal den Anspruch drauf erhebt dass
umsetzen wollen darauf vorbereitet zu
wollen
die vom Bundesminister hat eben im Jahr
2021 dieses streitkräfteprofil unser
Herr
ausgewählt und das stellt eben hier auf
eine schutzoperation ab wieder Herr
generalstoffchef richtig ausgeführt hat
und der seinerzeitige Bericht von
damaligen Bundesminister stalinger
Bericht 2030 wo eben 16 Milliarden
gefordert wurden auch diese 16
Milliarden haben nur darauf abgestellt
um uns zu einer schutzoperation zu
befähigen und nicht für eine Abwehr
Operation ich zitiere einen Satz aus
diesem Bericht vom Minister Starlinger
eine Ausrichtung des österreichischen
Bundesheers auf die Abwehr eines
konventionellen Angriffes Operation
würde die Verfügbarkeit von Mitteln in
Höhe von ca 2 % bedienen also deutlich
mehr als Minister Stallinger damals
gefordert hat und die
werbeauftragte des Deutschen Bundestages
SPD die fordert übrigens eine
sonderinvestition in Höhe von
100 Milliarden in Deutschland als
anstatt der 100 Milliarden die dort
beschlossen wurde und das zusätzlich zum
regelbudget von zwei Prozent des
angestrebt wird in Deutschland und wenn
wir das mit dem Faktor 10
herunterbrechen auf Österreich dann
sehen wir wie weit wir eigentlich trotz
dieser massiven budgeerhöhung von diesem
Sollzustand immer noch entfernt sind
meine Devise lautet wir müssen uns auf
einen Verteidigungsfall vorbereiten also
auf die aus unserer Sicht ungünstige
Variante und wenn wir darauf vorbereitet
sind dann können wir auch in einer
schutzoperation bestehen
[Applaus]
vielen Dank Herr Präger dir möchte mich
auch als Fan ihres Dachverbandes Orten
denke nur ein wehrhaftes Österreich ein
Land das ich wer kann ist auch ein
wahrhaftiges Österreich weil es sonst
irgendwann nicht mehr
bestehen wird zum Aufbauplan er hat
General einiges schon gesagt es ist
alles zu unterstreichen auch von den
Prioritäten hier aus meiner Sicht ich
würde sagen wir so nennen der Weg ist
das Ziel zehn Jahre ist eine lange Zeit
in der Politik aber wir alle brauchen
mehr Weitblick noch in Zukunft und das
Militär hat durchs eigentlich noch viel
komplexer sie braucht eigentlich
weltblick
weil wir
die Lage eigentlich noch bis vor dem 24
Februar des Vorjahres
unterschätzt haben wir wissen was
gefolgt ist
ein Wermutstropfen bei den Budgetmittel
ist vielleicht der dass es nicht
verfassungsrechtlich abgesichert ist
also die Sozialdemokratie wäre dem nicht
entgegen gestanden hier nachhaltig mit
Sicherheit planen zu können wäre es
meiner Sicht wichtig gewesen
ich bezeichne den materiellen aufwuchs
jetzt als durchaus moderat es ist nicht
die
Bazooka die wie in Deutschland
angeworfen wurde mit 100 Milliarden es
ist auch nicht dass
neutralitätspaket mit 10 Milliarden aber
es ist ein aufwuchs der von
Beständigkeit zeugt und hier ist auch
etwas zu schaffen
wichtig bei der Beschaffung ist mir die
Transparenz um nicht wieder zu
Erlebnisse zu haben wie beim bei der
Beschaffung der Eurofighter die ja durch
viele zu vielen Verwerfungen gekommen
sind auch in der politischen Natur und
am Ende des Tages dann auch ein tanea
Geschenk an den Steuerzahler wurden
möchte aber jetzt nicht die das Gerät
kritisieren das ist schon ein Top Gerät
der Eurofighter wieder
Beschaffungsvorgang vor sich gegangen
ist das war alles andere als gut
die Investition in die Mobilität ist
natürlich
zwingend und richtig und ich möchte es
auch im Ausdruck vorhin wir reden von
Ausrüstung unserer Soldaten sie modern
auszurüsten und hier muss man auch als
Politiker den Medien ein bisschen was
erklären weil ständig von Aufrüstung in
Österreich gesprochen wird also
Aufrüstung
tatsächlich sind sind wir sehr weit
entfernt obwohl natürlich
autarke Kasernen cybersicherheit neben
der schon erwähnten
beschaffungsmodalitäten eine sehr sehr
große
Herausforderung sind und die Zeit drängt
die Zeit drängt auch
nicht nur im materiellen mittlerweile
noch einmal beim personellen aufwuchs
schon fast mehr sorgen die flugtation
insbesondere in der Ruag sollte uns
Sorgen machen nämlich auch in Bezug auf
unserem Motor der Armee der kleine
Verbände die Bataillone wenn wir hier
Personal noch zusätzlich verlieren
werden irgendwann nicht mehr in der Lage
sein bitte und Anführungszeichen
gefechtsbereit zu sein und hier spielt
natürlich auch die Miliz aber ich glaube
da kann man dann nachher noch dazu eine
ganz entscheidende Rolle
wo sie immer wieder höre gibt es auch
teilweise
Konkurrenzsituation Polizei Österreich
Bundeswehr ich glaube das sollten wir
auch politisch auflösen weil es weil es
völlig andere Aufgaben sind am Ende des
Tages und ich keine Freude habe sondern
der Stellungskommission so für die
Polizei geworden wird finde ich nicht
ganz
gut und in der zukünftigen Organisation
beber-bummel
gehen in Pension die Einstiegsgehälter
und das ist wirklich eine politische
Forderung jetzt die müssen erhöht werden
um ihr auch
dementsprechend den personellen
Nachwuchs den wir dringend brauchen zu
erreichen vielen Dank
[Applaus]
vielen Dank wunderschönen guten Abend
ich kann nur ganz kurz erwähnen vor drei
Jahren die erste grüne da da war und ich
verstehe es nicht weil eigentlich ist
eine super Veranstaltung und ihm
interessant also gratulation dafür
und ich freue mich dass wir heute auch
ein politischer Runde haben weil
wertigen glaubt dass unter den Grünen
quasi das Militärbudget erhöht wird das
bin ich viel geredet worden dazu nicht
desto trotz ich glaube es ist notwendig
wir haben nicht nur die Sicherheit zu
erhöhen nämlich die Beschützung der
Bevölkerung und der Staatsgebiet sondern
auch nämlich viel weiter nämlich auch in
Krisenzeiten ist es das Bundesheer das
da ist sie sind es sie und ihren
Kommando haben immer zu helfen wenn die
Menschen Not ist weil es ist einfach das
Bundesheer das quasi wenn oder man ist
da ist und ich finde das sehr wichtig
auch zu normal zu betonen auch mal
vielen Dank an sie alle die sich im
Bundesheer engagieren dafür dass sie
wirklich weitergeht dass wir geholfen
wird dass ist und ich glaube ich finde
auch Wertschätzung und ich bin
Generalstab immer wieder in Austausch
also ich kann jetzt gerne viel mehr
erzählen weil wir sind sehr eng
natürlich weil wir brauchen ein
politisches commitment was wir umsetzen
wollen und das funktioniert tadellos und
ich bin sehr stolz darauf dass wir eine
Generalstab haben die hier eine sehr
gute Arbeit macht die einen Plan hat
kurzfristig mittelfristig und auch
langfristig wohin die Reise gehen soll
und meine Aufgabe unsere Aufgabe ist es
die politischen Rahmenbedingungen zu
gestalten und da muss ich mich beim
Douglas soll das jetzt wirklich
anschließend auch die umfassende
Landesverfassung
umfassende Landesverteidigung ist ein
Punkt der nicht nur irgendwo Papier
steht in einer Verfassung sondern
wirklich umgesetzt werden muss wir haben
das Szene wirtschaftlichen
Landesverteidigung wie schlecht wir sind
also ihre eine Energiekrise ich rede ein
Medikamenten für Vorbereitung alles drum
dran bis mein Lieblingsthema du bist das
Wissen cooking chill was das für ein
Problem ist
die sind so meine lieblings
gesehen zu Intelligenz in den Kasernen
das sind alles Probleme die wir
ansprechen müssen die wir umsetzen
müssen weil das hat nichts mit
irgendwelchen
Umweltschutzgedanken jetzt nicht nur zu
tun sondern das sind Gedanken die
nämlich die Resilienz die Wehrhaftigkeit
Österreichs nämlich auch die
Durchhaltefähigkeit nämlich hinaus
bringt und verlängert und ich bin
wirklich froh darüber dass wir auch in
der geistlichen und Landesverteidigung
was weiterbringen und weiterbringen
müssen weil ich weiß Schatz wieder in
die ersten zwei rein wie viel also man
hat ja sich relativ viel Zeit gelassen
bis wir zum Entschluss gekommen sind bis
November und die Leute sind schon sehr
nervös geworden also ich habe dort
täglich Anrufe bekommen
täglich Anrufe bekomme schon rein quasi
was passiert warum kommt kein Bundeswehr
Budget waren wo kommt die wann kommt der
Beschluss natürlich erst wenn der
Finanzgesetz auch steht und wir haben
das finde ich sehr gut rüber umgesetzt
wir haben das Gesetz abgesichert bis
2032 viele haben uns das nicht zugetraut
viele haben gesagt es wird nie zu kommen
aber es ist gekommen ich bin sehr stolz
auf darauf dass wir uns bis 2032 kommen
Mitmenschen
beigetragen es ist halt auch sehr
schwierig ein ich sage es ganz offen
heraus ein Gesetz ein Budget im
Verfassungsrang zu verankern es würden
dann sehr viele Türen geöffnet werden
andere Punkte im Verfassungsrang zu
nehmen und die EU hätte uns das nicht so
einfach toleriert ein Gesetz so
langfristig nämlich abzusichern ich
glaube und ich bin auch der festen
Überzeugung hier auch wenn man hier die
Werfer Sprecher haben die Partei die
Regierung die dieses Gesetz zurücknimmt
das schauen wir dann gerne mal an ich
glaube das wird nicht passieren weil es
einfach auch notwendig ist in die 16
Jahren auch zu investieren und die
Punkte
wir Grüne haben immer gesagt auch mit
gemeinsam mit dem Generalstab und mit
der Frau Bundesministerin dass wir
gerade eine Mobilität im Schutz der
Soldaten und Soldaten und da sie wissen
ich bin ein da kommen zum Nachhinein
auch zum Personal weniger Beamtenschaft
mehr in die mehr hinaus an die
Mannschaft eine Truppe einer der
wichtigsten Punkte neben auch der
Resilienz und Ausgestaltung sowie für
die Sicherheit der Soldatinnen quasi
auch aufzustocken viele andere Punkte
wie die Verbesserung der Kunden auch
dazu ist einer der sichten Punkte warum
weil das nämlich dazu führt das ist die
Visitenkarte des Bundesheers und diese
Visitenkarte und da Kollege hat gesagt
Chef des Generalstabs
das ist notwendig warum damit das
Bundesheer attraktiv bleibt auch als
Arbeitgeber dann müssen wir jetzt auch
aktiv werden das sind auch diese
Herausforderungen die wir haben in den
nächsten Jahren nicht nur an Material
sondern auch an Aktivität des
Bundesheers zu arbeiten aber das geht
jetzt viel zu weit gerne später dann
einmal aber das sind die Punkte die wir
auch vorhaben und auch umsetzen müssen
weil da geht es um etwas da geht's auch
um einen Arbeitgeber da geht's auch um
das dass das Bundeswehr aber dazu okay
das ist könnte
[Applaus]
vielen Dank Brigitte
ja ich denke Herr general Striedinger
hat auf sehr prägnante und
eindrucksvolle Art und Weise den
Aufbauplan 2032 dargestellt aus meiner
politischen Sicht ist dem nicht mehr
viel hinzuzufügen das ist nur zu
unterstreichen und auch politisch zu
unterstützen
ich denke auch dass wir mit dem was wir
in der Regierung im Parlament erreicht
haben mit dem budgetbeschluss der jetzt
schon diskutiert wurde und auch
vorgestellt wurde dass wir tatsächlich
einen verteidigungspolitischen
Meilenstein erreicht haben und ich
ersuche doch wir dürfen nicht den Fehler
machen dass wir
mit immer weiteren vorderen und
Forderungen und ich weiß schon genug ist
nicht genug und wird wahrscheinlich nie
genug sein aber wir dürfen uns dabei
nicht selbst blockieren wir müssen diese
diese Kraft in diese finanzielle Kraft
die wir jetzt beschlossen haben müssen
wir wenn du das so sagen darf müssen wir
auf die Straße bringen das ist glaube
ich jetzt unsere Herausforderung in den
nächsten zehn Jahren daran müssen wir
arbeiten dass wir uns nicht selbst
blockieren sondern wirklich diese Mittel
die uns jetzt zur Verfügung stehen
tatsächlich auch in den Einsatz bringen
und zum Einsatz bringen das ist glaube
ich das Wichtigste
sehr beeindruckend war für mich auch
general und das ist vielleicht und auch
im Zusammenhang mit der geistigen
Landesverteidigung die bereits
angesprochen wurde nicht nicht
unbeachtlich dass natürlich auch
Ausgaben für Militär für das
österreichische Bundesheer immer wieder
sozusagen ein Kind der Zeit sind und im
zeitlichen Kontext und im geopolitischen
Kontext zu sehen sind auch die
umfassende Landesverteidigung wurde
1975 in der Verfassung verankert und ich
habe mich jetzt das gegebenen Anlass mit
den Ereignissen 1973 beschäftigt das
heißt begonnen hat mit dem junggeburt
Krieg mit der Ölkrise der Kalte Krieg an
Höhepunkt die Gefahr eines Atomkrieges
atomschlages gegeben mich kenne es aus
meiner früheren beruflichen
Beschäftigung in der
niederösterreichischen Bauordnung die
Schutzräume waren verankert heute kein
Thema mehr
was ich damit sagen will ist dass
natürlich dieses Bewusstsein von
betrogenslagen verloren gegangen ist und
nach 1991 nach dem Krieg in Jugoslawien
2002/2003 im Rahmen dieses
geopolitischen Kontextes sind dann auch
die entsprechenden Entscheidungen zu
beurteilen und getroffen worden
für uns ist jetzt die Herausforderung
dass wir
diese geopolitische Situation
den Rückkehr eines die Rückkehr eines
konventionellen Krieges in Europa dass
wir dieses Bedrohungsszenario und wenn
ich jetzt sage aufrechterhalten dann
klingt es klingt das dramatisch klingt
das zu negativ wir dürfen auch nicht
Angst und Panik verbreiten sondern wir
müssen das Bewusstsein dafür schaffen
welche Bedrohungen es gibt in einer
modernen Welt das reicht von wie wir
gesehen haben konventionellen
Bedrohungen im militärischen Bereich bis
hin zu Hybriden Bedrohungen wo sozusagen
jeder Computer eines jeden Zivilisten
auch zum Teil einer Waffe werden kann
auch diese Bedrohungen müssen wir uns
Sorgen halten und in dieser Richtung
gilt es die geistige Landesverteidigung
zu stärken
die Neutralität wurde ja auch normiert
zum Zweck der
Gewährleistung der unfrisst
Unverletzlichkeit ist des Staatsgebietes
und der Souveränität Österreichs und der
zweite Satz lautet ja es wird Österreich
wird diese mit allen Angebote stehenden
Mitteln verteidigen dieser zweite Satz
mit allen Angebote stehenden Mitteln
verteidigen ist in den letzten
Jahrzehnten eher
unterbelichtet gewesen durch dieses
dramatische Ereignis durch den
Angriffskrieg auf die Ukraine ist es
wieder ins Bewusstsein gelangt dass es
durchaus notwendig ist auch sich zu
verteidigen aber das sind die wir schon
bei der Grundsatzfrage Frage des wer
Willens was verteidigen wir was ist das
wertverteidigt zu werden wer verteidigt
überhaupt
irgendjemanden und da bin ich wieder bei
der geistigen Landesverteidigung dass
wir dieses Bewusstsein wieder wecken
müssen dass wir wahrscheinlich auch sehr
breit in die Bevölkerung hineingehen
müssen um dieses Bewusstsein zu stärken
diese
neudeutsch Stakeholder beginnt
wahrscheinlich schon in der Schule
wahrscheinlich ein Gedanke auch es gibt
uns strategischen Führungslehrgang den
ich selbst auch absolviert habe ein
hervorragender Lehrgang darf dazu auch
keine Werbung machen aber vielleicht
wäre eine solche ein solcher lehrung in
etwas abgespeckter Art und Weise auch
für
Direktoren DirektorInnen für das
Lehrpersonal für alle die mit
Jugendausbildung zu tun haben auch etwas
um den Gedanken der geistigen
Landesverteidigung
breit zu streuen nicht um aus allen
Kindern oder Jugendlichen Militaristen
zu machen sondern um ein gesundes
Bewusstsein für Bedrohungen zu schaffen
und wie man diesen Bedrohungen begegnen
kann
[Applaus]
[Musik]
herzlichen Dank für diese erste Runde an
sie es ist ja im Rückblick auf die
vergangenen zehn Jahre in der
Darstellung von brigadeur Fender war
auch ein Bild dabei es gab schon einmal
so ein oder mehrfach solche bodien der
wehrsprecher und
man muss dazu sagen da war es immer
möglich diesen Konsens herzustellen denn
sie auch heute angesprochen und
dargestellt haben und
die Kunst ist es diesen Konsens aber
dann über den heutigen Tag hinaus in die
Realität zu bringen das ist in der
Vergangenheit muss ich sagen meine
Einschätzung nicht immer gelungen ich
glaube dass es diesmal einen großen
Unterschied gibt das ist die geänderte
Geopolitik im Vergleich jetzt zu einem
Jahr 20 15 oder zu einem Jahr 2016 und
es gibt noch einen Unterschied ich denke
die Soldaten die Führungskräfte die
Offiziere des österreichischen
Bundesheers haben auch in den letzten
Monaten und Jahren in ihren Analysen in
ihren Szenarien die Sie vorab
in in risikobilder eingebracht haben
aber auch in den Analysen und
Kommentaren zur aktuellen Lage bewiesen
dass sie vollkommen kreuzvernünftige
Menschen sind die
solide denken und dass deren Urteil
einen Wert hat und das war glaube ich in
der öffentlichen Meinung nicht immer so
dass das positiv geschätzt wurde und
dass man da zugehört hat und ich denke
das ist ein asset dass wir vielleicht
jetzt auch nutzen können oder auch
nutzen sollen
was uns noch nie gelungen ist auf diesem
Podium war einen Konsens zu erzielen zu
dieser Frage mit den mit der
übungspflicht seit 2006 seit damals die
die Übungen abgeschafft wurden gibt es
dazu unterschiedliche Gesichtspunkte es
ist vielleicht auch einfach über Budgets
Einigkeit zu haben da gibt man das Geld
anderer Leute aus bei den Übungen geht
es darum ums eigene G&D zu einem Teil
auch und das muss dann auch irgendwie
sozusagen befriedigt werden und daher
möchte aber trotz alledem noch einmal
dieses Thema Aufwärmen nachdem es so ein
Zett darum Senseo unseres Dachverbandes
ist die Rückkehr zu den verpflichtenden
Übungen
was sie dem für eine Chance oder
Bedeutung oder Richtigkeit
einordnen und diesmal gehen die andere
Richtung von der jetzt amtierenden
Regierung die ist sozusagen gesagt hat
wissen wie es ist und schauen uns dann
an wie die
Oppositionsvertreter das Kommentieren
ich bitte Sie wieder um um kurz in dem
Fall um kürzere Antworten als auf die
erste
vielen Dank ich denke mir wenn wir
darüber sprechen dann sprechen wir das
Grundproblem Personalgewinnung wie
gewinnen wir das Personal wir haben das
Problem oder wir werden das Problem
haben wir haben teilweise jetzt schon
aber in Zukunft noch mehr Personal in
ausreichender Quantität aber auch
Qualität zu finden
der Begriff der Pflicht oder
Verpflichtungen hat sich in den letzten
Jahren Jahrzehnten auch sehr stark
gewandelt und letztlich geht es auch um
die Frage wie motiviere ich Menschen das
zu tun was was sie tun
das kann man mit Geld machen das kann
man mit gesetzlichen Verpflichtungen
machen die Frage ist das kann man mit
Attraktivität des Dienstgebers machen
die Frage ist was wirkt am besten
die gesetzliche Verpflichtung ist
derzeit
Regierungsprogramm mäßig nicht abgedeckt
das ist so gesehen so gesehen relativ
klar ist aber auch für mich eine
auch eine Frage der des Verständnisses
Notwendigkeit auch wieder der geistigen
Landesverteidigung
und wir versuchen im Sinne der Worte
designal striedrich eine freiwillige
Selbstverpflichtung herbeizuführen indem
wir
motivations-ausbildung meldet mein
Dienst für Österreich wenn man sich
meldet für eine rasche
Reaktionskraft in der Miliz gibt es
mittlerweile Prämien und ich denke mir
dass
Soldatinnen Soldaten die sich freiwillig
melden weil sie das was sie tun gerne
tun auch eine entsprechend hohe
Motivation haben wir versuchen es über
diesen Bereich einmal zu schaffen das
ist eine Bereich und der zweite Bereich
ist natürlich auch ein attraktiver
Dienstwagen attraktiver dann wenn
entsprechend modernes Gerät vorhanden
ist mit dem man als Soldatin als Soldat
gerne übt gerne in den Einsatz geht wenn
moderne Kasernen da sind wo auch die
Ausstattung und die Unterkunft
entsprechend gegeben ist
denke das sind
Grundsätze und Prinzipien wo wir auch
darauf bauen dass das auch zu einer
verstärkten verstärkten Meldung auch in
die Milz
beitragen wird natürlich auch Übungen da
gibt es schon entsprechend aussagen dass
auch die Übungstätigkeit entsprechend
ausgeweitet werden soll ich glaube dass
auch das Üben mit modernem Gerät auch
wieder diejenigen die jetzt vielleicht
ihre Verpflichtung nicht so wahrgenommen
haben und sich gerne befreien haben
lassen und vielleicht wieder mehr
motiviert auch sich zu melden
soweit in aller Kürze alles weitere
würde noch etwas zu weit führen
[Applaus]
ich glaube welches Unternehmen hat
aktuell oder zeigen Sie mir das
Unternehmen was aktuell kein
Fachkräftemangel hat zeigen Sie mir das
es wird es einfach nicht geben aktuell
und wir haben einen Vorteil im
Bundesland wir holen zumindest knapp 50%
der jungen Menschen der männlichen
Menschen in die in die Kaserne und wohl
und holen sie ins Bundeswehr und dieses
eine Punkt gelingt uns noch nicht voll
erzähle ich dass wir so ein attraktiver
Arbeitgeber sind dass wir so attraktiv
sind dass die dann sagen wir bleiben
freiwillig dazu das ist ein Punkt wir
haben diesen riesen Vorteil gegenüber
den Unternehmen das wird quasi alle
hierher holen können im Jahr und so
bestmöglich von unserer Arbeit vom
Bundesheer überzeugen können wenn ich
jetzt mit jungen Menschen und das gebe
ich die absolut Recht die du zuerst
gesagt hat da hat sich ein Wandel
gegeben und auch bei den Grund wird
ihnen hat es am Wandel gegeben früher
hat's gegessen das Bundeswehr hat kaputt
passiert eh nichts den ganzen Tag ich
bin dafür hat er das Assistenzeinsatz
also das also ich habe mich das sehr oft
schon auch mit Koalitionspartner schon
öfters angelegt dazu
weil ich ich glaube das Grundwehrdiener
ein Weg zu einem ausgebildeten Soldat
sein soll ein Weg hin noch nicht fertig
vielleicht aber dorthin und dann in der
Miliz vielleicht auch zum Soldaten wird
und das was wir machen in drei Monaten
das finde ich verkürzt in zwei Monaten
300 ein Soldat an der Grenze zu stehen
ist nicht mein Zugang das kann ich nicht
verantworten das haben wir auch als
Bundesregierung also das ist im
Regierungsprogramm so gesehen und werden
auch die Grunde Diener abziehen sind zum
Nachteil anderer wieder also ich würde
also dass er der andere politische
Diskussion aber nicht desto trotz ich
glaube wir brauchen aber hier eine
Attraktivierung wir brauchen sinnvoll
sind stiftende Arbeit wir müssen das
Bundeswehr im Werding in der Wahrnehmung
in der außen Wahrnehmung und das
passiert jetzt bereits auch damit mir
immer reden also die Außenwahrnehmung
das ist ja alles schlechter kann man
jetzt schießen das ändert sich weil wir
investieren weil das jetzt passiert weil
Übungen geschehen weil Material
angekauft wird weil wieder etwas
geschieht und ich glaube das ist ein Weg
zur richtigen in die richtige Richtung
dass wir attraktiv an das Bundesheer und
das junge Menschen sich auch begeistern
dafür dabei zu bleiben und auch in den
milzsicherung sie wissen und ich mache
da kein Hehl daraus ich bin nicht dafür
war dafür sechs plus zwei oder für weil
es auch den Zivildienst verlängert das
ist kein Geheimnis ich möchte es zuerst
mit Freiwilligkeit probieren und wenn
und das können wir uns gerne sagen wir
sehr gut gefallen wenn man dann schauen
dass es wirklich nicht funktioniert dass
wir ein Problem haben dann schauen wir
weiter und ich bin der fest Überzeugung
auch in diesem Konsens unter den Wert
sprechen wir werden Lösungen finden ich
kann es garantieren ich habe eine sehr
gute Zusammenarbeit es ist mir der
Liebste Ausschuss jetzt in vielen
Ausschüssen aber da war der
Landesverteidigung ist der wo wir am
meisten konzentrieren wo auch andere
Opposition die uns gemeinsam anschauen
und so einen Antrag zusammen finden wo
wir Lösungen finden weil wir ein gutes
unter ein gemeinsames haben nämlich das
irgendwelche Bundesheer und dafür setzen
wir uns alle ein und ich finde das auch
der Weg wie wir auch weiter vorgehen
sollten in diesem Bereich also vielen
Dank
[Applaus]
ich denke
seit dem Vorjahr seit der zweiten Wände
und das war der deutsche Bundeskanzler
mit diesem Wort am besten und
eindrucksvollsten geprägt denke ich und
diese Zeitenwende ist irreversibel geht
auch einher dass wir in einer
resilientengesellschaft aufbauen
eigentlich müssen genau Resilienz
eine resiliente Gesellschaft
weiterentwickeln das braucht einen
starken Staat es braucht viel
Unterstützung da muss Politik begleiten
und ich denke man soll
über Resilienz auch neue Methoden denken
und es gibt
die Wehrpflicht es gibt den Ersatzdienst
und warum soll man auch nicht beim
Zivildienst über ein Milizsystem
zumindestens Andenken um hier milizismus
wir möchten abschließend persönlich
erfahren sondern ich war am Wochenende
am Tag der offenen Tür am Parlament
kommt der junger Mann zu mir so Mitte 30
hätten geschätzter wollten auch seinen
Namen gar nicht sagen wollte nur sein
problemlos werden es war echt eins ist
das ist auch gescheiter Mann Akademiker
Kurzarbeiter Nationalbank
beworben
nur beim
Bewerbungsgespräch nicht
aufnahmebewährungsgespräch wurde ihm
zur Last gelegt eigentlich als Barriere
hingestellt dass er Miliz offiziell ist
also das kann es wirklich sein private
Wirtschaft ist man einiges muss man noch
viel verbessern aber ein staatlichen
Institutionen da braucht man dann nicht
mehr vor Freiwilligkeit oder Zwang reden
da geht es einfach um mentalitätsproblem
und das haben wir es Politiker gefordert
[Applaus]
ich muss mich gleich entschuldigen aber
diese Frage ist mir eine derartige
Herzensangelegenheit dass ich mich nicht
ganz kurz halten kann das ist für mich
eines der als der wichtigsten Themen
sozusagen überhaupt in der militärischen
landesverträgen und warum ich mich
politisch engagiere und ich bin auch der
einzige Militär hier unter den wer
sprechen und dumm möchte da ein bisschen
weiter ausholen Ihnen hier am Tag der
Wehrpflicht erzähle ich natürlich nichts
Neues wenn ich sage das sind Park auf 79
Absatz 1 BVG drinnen steht dass das
Bundesheer nach den Grundsätzen des
militärsystems einzurichten ist und wie
wir aus den parlamentarischen
Erläuterungen aus der seinerzeitigen
Regierungsvorlage entnehmen können ist
bei dies nach dem Vorbild dass Schweizer
militärsystems auszurichten nur leider
ist es so dass das passiert zum einen
der Verfassung steht aber zum anderen in
der Praxis leider hat es keinen hier
sicher nicht widerspiegelt in der Praxis
und das hat auch ganz deutlich der
Rechnungshofbericht vom dezember des
letzten Jahres bestätigt leider Gottes
und ich sage es jetzt bewusst ein
bisschen überspitzt ich bin der Meinung
dass wir in Österreich wenn wir den
Ist-Zustand beurteilen in Wahrheit eine
Art
Berufs her haben dass sich den
Grundwehrdienern als billige
systemerhaltern bedient und die Miliz
die wir in den 90er Jahren das letzte
jahrhunderts noch hatten Stichwort
drin und raumverteidigung die gibt es
leider nicht einmal mehr ansatzweise
mehr und ich habe in meine militärischen
Anfangsjahren die volltruppenübungen
noch selbst miterlebt und diese Militär
hat man leider Gottes politisch
mutwillig ruiniert und der Grund war
damals der seinerzeitige
Verteidigungsminister Günther der für
ein billiges mal Zuckerl damals die in
Grunddienst von 8 Monate auf 6 Monate
verkürzt hat und damit die
verpflichteten puppenübungen abgeschafft
hat übrigens damals hat man gesagt das
macht man unter der Bedingung aus der
Assistenzeinsatz ändert der dann nicht
geändert hat und das führt jetzt zu dem
groteskenergebnis dass wir zwar
Grundwehrdiener ausbilden kleine
seitenbemerkung auch nur schlecht und
unzureichend weil zu kurz in der Praxis
weil wir die Grundwehrdiener an die
Grenze schicken zu einem
Assistenzeinsatz und das wird daher
Fender heute schon hervorragend gesagt
der in dieser Form wir gemacht wird
vollkommen sinnlos ist weil das ist kein
Grenzschutz sondern das ist ein
Escortservice für die Migranten die dort
abgeholt werden aber nicht abgehalten
werden von unserer Grenze
und das grotesk ist dass wir diese
Grundwehrdiener dann nach sechs Monaten
in den immerwährenden zivilen Ruhestand
schicken und das vorhandene militärische
Know-how leider nicht für die Miliz
weiter nutzen und von unserem
mobilenmachungsrahmen von 55.000 Mann
gibt es laut BMLV so rund 35
000 milizoldaten und von diesen 35000
angeblichen menüsoldaten sind fast die
Hälfte sogenannte befristete beorderte
ihnen brauche ich aber nicht erklären
dass ein befristet bei order da kein
richtiger milit Soldat ist denn Miliz
zeichnet sich dadurch aus dass sie
regelmäßig übt und die befristet
beorderten die nehmen nach Ableistung
ihres Grundwehrdienst an keiner einzigen
milzübung Teil ich habe in meiner ganzen
militärischen Laufbahn noch keinen
befristeten beorderten jemals in einer
Kaserne gesehen wir haben die Namen und
die Daten dieser befristet beorderten
immer nur in unseren ortsplänen stehen
aber zu Gesicht bekommen wird die
Kameraden nie das sind also leider
Gottes militärische Karteileichen aber
keine milit Soldaten unsere milizs die
wir jetzt noch haben die besteht
hauptsächlich erstens einmal aus den
alten die noch aus dem früheren System
kommen die großteils halt immer wieder
freiwillig weiter unterschrieben haben
so wie ich selbst auch dann zweitens aus
den wenigen leider viel zu wenigen
jungen Freiwilligen und drittens die
Party verpflichtet werden weil sie
vielleicht ehemalige kp-soldaten sind
etc und daneben viertens aus diesen
befristeten beorderten die keine
milizoldaten sind und wenn wir hier
nichts ändern dann wird unsere stark
überaltete Miliz in ein paar Jahren
wirklich aussterben und wenn seitens der
Regierungsfraktionen dann immer von
einer freiwilligen Miliz gesprochen wird
dann möchte ich schon ins Bewusstsein
rufen die befristet beorderten auf die
ihr ein Großteil ein großer Teil der
Miliz hier setzt das sind keine
Freiwilligen die sind unfreiwillig
befristete unterhalten im Bereich und
ja general ich habe eigentlich fast
alles unterstreichen können und und ich
bedanke mich auch für die ehrlichen
Worte heute die sie hier gesprochen
haben nur bei einem einzigen Punkt da
kann ich nicht mitgehen und zwar mit dem
freiwilligen System wir haben jetzt über
viele viele Jahre wirklich versucht mit
freiwilligen Anreizen oder mit mit guten
Anreizen hier finanziellen Anreize etc
des freiwilligen System am Leben zu
erhalten oder oder aufzubauen und ich
spreche wirklich auch ein großes Lob an
das Resort aus der Brigitte Thaler
versucht hier wirklich sehr kreativ
Anreize zu setzen und neue zu erfinden
nur leider gelingt es damit einfach
nicht die notwendigen Mann Stärken zu
erreichen und das sollten wir eigentlich
inzwischen bereits gelernt haben und
nicht weiterhin jetzt hier wertvolle
Zeit zu verschwenden indem man weiter
versucht hier auf die Freiwilligkeit zu
setzen und wenn man sich den
Verpflichteten Truppenübungen
verschließt dann klingt der hat aber
dann will man in Wahrheit keine Milz
sondern da will man am besten falls eine
Reserve um Lücken im bestehenden System
und Fehlstellen
zu schließen und verpflichtete
Truppenübungen kann man eigentlich nur
dann ablehnen wenn man entgegen unsere
Bundesverfassung und entgegen dem
Ergebnis der Volksbefragung vor zehn
Jahren in Wahrheit doch lieber ein Beruf
sehr hätte und dennoch werden sich die
Regierungsfraktionen hier leider dagegen
und ich Interessiere kritisiere auch die
Sprechweise der vom Bundesminister
schade dass sie jetzt nicht mehr da ist
wird aber offiziersperger noch mal sagen
sie spricht ganz gern dass die Miliz ein
wesentlicher Bestandteil unseres
Bundesheeres ist
ein wesentlicher Bestandteil wenn man
das so sagt dann klingt das so als wäre
die Milz eine Art Teilstreitkraft
unseres Bundesheers aber dann hat man
eigentlich nicht verstanden dass laut
Bundesverfassung unsere gesamte
Einsatzorganisation nach dem Milizsystem
auszurichten ist und wir fordern daher
als freiheitliche die Wiederherstellung
des verfassungskonformen Zustandes
welche unserer Ansicht nach nur durch
verpflichtende Truppenübungen geschehen
kann hier nach dem früheren Modell 8
Monate das heißt
für Masse die Masse der Soldaten nach
dem System 6 plus 2 und ein weiterer
Aspekt vielleicht ein neuer man könnte
auch darüber nachdenken ob man parallel
zur unserer milits vielleicht eine auch
eine Art
zivildienstmiliz ins Leben ruft das wäre
vielleicht interessant dass zum einen da
das Bundesheer nicht noch attraktiver
wird unattraktiver wird im Vergleich zum
Zivil ist und zum anderen dass man für
so nicht militärische
Assistenzleistungen gerade in der
Gesundheitskrise dass man hier
vielleicht auf eine Milz von
Zivildienern zurückgreifen könnte und
nicht hier die Grundwehrdiener und milit
Soldaten eigentlich für solche artfremde
Aufgaben missbrauchen muss
[Applaus]
ich muss anfangen
zu ihrer Einleitung ganz kurz Stellung
nehmen weil sie gesagt haben das Budget
das wird der Einigkeit haben müssen eher
einfach weil man gibt das Geld anderer
Leute aus ich kann das zumindest für
meine Fraktion nicht sagen weil seitdem
ich wersprecher bin seit dem Jahr 2017
gibt es genau zwei Bereiche wo wir in
jedem Budget mehr Geld gefordert haben
dass eines Bildung ist glaube ich
relativ klar und das andere
Landesverteidigung also das ist nicht so
selbstverständlich glaube ich dass wir
hier Einigkeit haben ich werde mich
jetzt versuchen kurz zu halten weil sehr
viel schon gesagt wurde ich glaube zum
Thema milits ist das freiwilliges System
durchaus ein sehr gutes und Seins was
man weiter Andenken kann wenngleich wir
auch sagen müssen dass es momentan nicht
funktioniert das ist Faktor und das ist
dann natürlich auch ein Stück weit Geld
Verschwendung ist das muss man auch so
brutal sagen wenn wir Leute ausbilden
Soldaten ausbilden und sie dann nicht
einsetzen können das ist schade um das
Geld das muss man offen ehrlich sein das
heißt wir müssen schauen dass wir im
Anreizsystem Verbesserungen herstellen
und hier auch durchaus weiter denken als
wir das bisher getan haben also es gibt
ja in Nachbarstaaten Schweiz gibt es
Modelle wo das steuerliche Hintergründe
hat es gibt Möglichkeiten dass man
beispielsweise bei irgendwelchen
Gebühren Studiengebühren ähnliche Dinge
für Lehre hier Unterstützungsleistungen
anbringt oder umgekehrt Stipendien also
da gibt es durchaus wo man insbesondere
auch die in die Ausbildung der jungen
Menschen investiert auch außerhalb in
ihrer zivilen Funktion die sie dann inne
haben ich glaube das sind durchaus Dinge
die wir mitdenken können und wo wir
gesamt als Österreich also als wer
Sprecher aber auch als österreichisches
Bundesheer noch Schritte denken müssen
der zweite Punkt den ich glaube ich die
man nicht außer Acht lassen darf nämlich
auch in dem Kontext den wir heute hier
diskutieren ist durchaus dass Ansehen
des Soldaten
und das ist schon ein Thema was wir
haben es ist für viele junge Menschen
haben Sie das Gefühl dass sie mehr an
sie sehen haben wenn sie nachher zum
Roten Kreuz zum Samariterbund oder wo
auch immer ihren Zivildienst ableisten
das heißt wir müssen schon alle
gemeinsam daran arbeiten dass das
Ansehen des Soldaten egal ob es ein
Berufssoldat ist oder ein militsoldat in
den Vordergrund gerückt wird ich glaube
auch dafür ist natürlich der Punkt den
wir vorher alle glaube ich angesprochen
haben geistige Landesverteidigung hier
den Soldaten auch in den Mittelpunkt zu
stellen auch keine Berührungsängste zu
haben ich frage ganz offen und ehrlich
wir laden in Schulen ein Zeit im
bildmoderatoren wir laden Politiker ein
die dürfen nicht alleine erscheinen
sondern nur wenn alle Fraktionen kommen
oder ähnliches sagen Sie mir ehrlich wie
oft sind Schulen eingeladen wurden als
Soldaten das kommt sehr sehr selten vor
es kommt nur vor wenn vielleicht der
Vater beim österreichischen Bundesheer
ist oder sowas und das ist glaube ich
eine Barriere die wir auch
abbrechen müssen der Soldat ist nicht
der böse der alle Menschen
ähm keine Ahnung attackieren will
niederschissen will oder ähnliches
sondern da Soldat ist eine essentielle
Persönlichkeit in unserem Staat ist eine
essentielle Schutzfunktion in unserem
Stadt und ich glaube das darf man auch
nicht klein reden und die Angst davor
auch nicht nicht in der Bevölkerung
haben und dementsprechend ist das
Ansehen neben allen Anreizsystemen des
Berufs des Soldaten glaube ich etwas wo
wir alle gemeinsam maßgeblich daran
arbeiten müssen dass das auch wieder
besser wird
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren wir sind
in der Zeit weit fortgeschritten ich
glaube es ist auch nicht notwendig bei
so einem
illustriellen Publikum wie ihnen ähnlich
wie in einer Fernsehsendung Ihnen jetzt
zu erklären was sie gerade gesehen haben
die Worte der währsprecher haben für
sich gesprochen es ist Konsens und es
ist auch da und dort Dissens das gehört
in den politischen Dialog was aber
erfreulich ist ist die Liste in der das
abläuft und so freut es mich auch als
Gastgeber hier ein immer wieder ein
Podium zu bieten wo derartige Fragen in
einer
sehr kollegialen Tonalität geführt
werden bei aller Ernsthaftigkeit die
diese Fragen haben und wo auch etwaige
Fehlurteile eine schwere Konsequenz für
unsere Zukunft haben können für die
Existenz unserer Streitkräfte und
letztlich für den Auftrag unseres
Bundesheers
Schutz des Landes und seiner Bevölkerung
sicherzustellen wir sind damit am Ende
des heutigen Festaktes nicht am Ende des
Tages da Wehrpflicht endet um 24 Uhr
hier gibt es im Anschluss noch einen ein
kleines Buffet jene die schon ihren
Maskenball machen müssen und nachher auf
den anderen Ball zu gehen sind natürlich
bei diesem Buffet
entsprechend entschuldigt aber bevor wir
auseinander laufen würde ich Sie bitten
dass sie sich von den Plätzen erheben
und wir mit der Bundeshymne diesen
Festakt beenden
[Musik]
[Applaus]